9 30. I'm going to go ahead and start
the work session
is not going to be the most well
organized and from the exterior
professionally polished meetings you've
ever seen what we're going to generally
try to do
is work through all of our hb2 items and
put them into buckets the items that we
think we you know can agree to agree on
that we can just accept I'd like to go
ahead and vote on them and and and
have them categorized then if there are
still some hb2 items that we have you
know further discussion and caucuses on
you know we'll identify those and then
if there are some ones that we've agreed
to that need some changes then we'll
we'll do that as well so we'll I'd like
to have us as a goal for today to get
through all of the hb2 items and put
them in into one of these three buckets
okay
now
I I see people from the Department here
today
uh are you here for the whole day or are
you here for specific items that we
good morning Nathan white Chief
Financial Officer Department of Health
and Human Services
um I I had I had asked Henry Littman to
come here this morning to address the
rate questions around the Medicaid rates
and then Katya Fox is here to speak to
some of the appropriations of the
governor's commission and one of our one
of our prioritized needs as well
concerning dvh
and our associate commissioner Ann
Landry is here as well to answer
questions
okay so
um
so it's good because with Miss Fox here
and Mr lippman those those were two
early things I wanted to bring up anyway
so that that dovetails nicely
or when when Mr Ripple is ready
um I I think I'd like to start
um
I I don't know if we're going to be able
to come to any conclusions on this but
I'd like to start with the alcohol and
drug abuse prevention treatment and
Recovery commission issues there are two
hb2 items in there that we've discussed
in previous hearings section 89 section
99 and
um and and then there would be related
actions that we would take on hb1 Miss
Ripple has put together a package for us
with the summary sheet and then there
are some specific amendments that we
could we could vote on so go you want to
start us off sure and so I'll actually
start not with the summary sheet but
with the First Amendment the house bill
and this is sort of a complicated
Amendment but the goal is simple the
goal is to keep the five percent of
liquor revenues in the alcohol fund and
prevent them from being transferred to
the granted Advantage Program to help
so I'll go through this section by
section
but I'm not can I just come back and say
why we're doing this sure okay I I in in
my view what I'd like to have us trying
to do is to protect the alcohol and drug
commissions money the five percent that
they get from the alcohol
or from the alcohol fund and those
monies have periodically been tapped
into and used for other purposes of the
state and then we've found some ways to
backfill them and so I'd like to just
get that all cleaned up Let the alcohol
commission have their money uh if it was
five percent was committed and so so
what what I asked Mr Ripple to do was to
make it clear that that we want to
protect that five percent so that later
we can come back and clean up the
dysfunctional things we were doing
trying to to get access to some cash so
so that's that's what I think this bill
does do you want to go through the
sure
I'll actually start with Section Five of
the amendment which repeals certain
statutory Provisions relative to
transfers from the alcohol fund so these
are the statutes that require that that
five percent of liquor revenues be
transferred from the alcohol fund to
granted Advantage so those would be
going back to section one that section
would likewise
repeal a provision in existing statute
that refers to the transfer of alcohol
funds
of liquor funds rather from the alcohol
fund to granted Advantage so this is
just statutory cleanup to accomplish
what representative Edwards wanted to
accomplish
section two
is in recognition of the fact that New
Hampshire's hospitals are still
committed to
one last five million dollar voluntary
donation which I believe is scheduled to
take place at the end of this calendar
year
so section 2 would reduce the transfers
from liquor to the alcohol fund by the
amount of that donation so in other
words
if five percent of liquor revenues
equals 11 million dollars
and the hospitals give a five million
dollar donation the alcohol fund would
be kept whole at 11 million dollars but
six of it would come from liquor and
five million of it would come from the
donations
otherwise absent this section
the governor's commission and the
alcohol fund would get 11 million plus
sections three and four
are more statutory cleanup that relate
to the granted Advantage Program so I'm
going to try not to go into this in too
much detail but granted Advantage is
currently funded from a variety of
funding sources one of which is this
transfer from the alcohol fund if that
transfer from the alcohol fund is
removed then it disrupts other pieces of
the funding scheme
so three and four are designed to remedy
that and this language was taken
directly from Senate Bill 263 which is
the Senate bill that reauthorizes the
granted Advantage Program however
since this amendment
is not intended to reauthorize granted
Advantage you'll notice that there is
contingency language
on page two lines 14 through 16 that say
the sections three and four shall only
take effect if the granted Advantage
Program is reauthorized
so the other sections of this bill will
take effect no matter what three and
four only take effect if granted
Advantage is reauthorized I realize that
may have been a little bit convoluted so
if anybody has any questions please let
me know you know the fact that it's
convoluted I think it makes the point
that if we're going to try to clean this
up and provide everyone with
transparency and maintenance of
principles we've we've gotten it muddied
up and messed up and this is trying to
deconflict it so in the future we know
what we're doing and we you know know
how to talk about what we're doing so so
do you have go ahead representative
thank you I'm wondering if you could
give me an idea of how much money we're
talking about here that's being
transferred from the fund to Grant
Advantage Program it's about 11 million
per year 11
. in in that summary sheet that was on
the top of it that does kind of help in
that regard
representative Wallner
thank you I wonder if we could have
um Mr lippman talk just for a minute
about how all of this affects the
granite Advantage Program
good morning for the record uh Henry in
the state's Medicaid director thank you
for the question
um
I think that
the the expectation of how things were
going to potentially transition
um
in what Kevin Ripple has provided to you
is something that I've vetted with with
him
um so in terms of what we expect is that
the provision that was passed as part of
hb4 in 2019 that allows
Granite Advantage Program to tap into
a different liquor account if you will
to take to get to fill in any Gap that's
necessary that doesn't come through the
other funding sources
and that's that's a fixed amount
predicted
um
uh in Senate Bill 263 based on roughly
the number that's in here with a with an
inflation Factor so I think this all as
kept Kevin has explained it all holds
together
that if granted Advantage is
reauthorized that there is
um
all the pieces that stack up to provide
the non-federal share are there to uh to
support it if in fact it is reauthorized
it and if it helps represent walner one
one of the things I can tell you is it
feels to me like the GOP caucus is
leaning towards reauthorization of the
of the Granite State Advantage Program
the this the distinction we may have
with the Senate is we might rather than
make it permanent want to go ahead and
just come up with another grandfather or
Sunset date in the future so that that
that's the only debating Point not
okay
I just want a minute to take a look at
this
hmm
so if you're ready I can move on to the
next sheet I I think you're you're ready
I can move on to the house bill one
Amendment
so as you can see from the description
uh this amendment does a couple things
it assumes that five percent of gross
liquor profits will remain in the
alcohol fund and not be transferred to
granted advantage that's consistent with
the house bill 2 amendment that you just
saw
it also assumes that five percent of
gross liquor profits won't be the
roughly 10 million dollars that was in
the governor's budget but rather 11.1
million and 24 and 11 million in fiscal
25. excuse me that's consistent with the
revenue estimates that were adopted by
house Ways and Means
I I assume that you're talking
specifically to uh or what are you
talking to I'm talking to the one that
looks like a spreadsheet here
and finally it assumes one final five
million dollar donations will be made by
the hospitals in 24.
and that the transfer from liquor
revenues will be reduced accordingly
excuse me and again that's consistent
with section two of the House Bill 2
so if you go down to the bottom of this
in the change column for fiscal 24
down below where it says source of funds
005 private local funds that five
million dollars reflects reflects the
transfer from the hospitals or the
donation from the hospitals
and where you go down to the total under
revised budget it says 11.1 million and
twenty four and 11 million and 25 that
reflects the the total amount that the
alcohol fund would receive and those
amounts equate to an estimated five
percent of gross liquor profits in each
year
I'm waiting for questions or body
Mr chair
representable I have a 10 o'clock Bill
introduction in division two that I will
go ahead
said Kevin could can you address the
change the 389 the 3.8 million in the
change column
talk again about that that is the
reduction in agency income that agency
income refers to
what would now be the term the transfer
from liquor so that's going down because
this amendment assumes the 5 million
can I just ask is that
is that something the hospitals
have verified with us
yes
um it's actually their CMS in terms of
viewing our funding for granted
Advantage
came back with
change in administrations that that that
that that source of funding because
there's a connection between
um the people being covered that they
didn't want that to be in place and they
gave us uh the chance to unwind if you
will the uh the timing of it with the
last donation that was agreed to and so
that is something that uh We've
acknowledged with them that we would
comply with
thank you
to to the follow-up to that I think is
was that yes we have confirmed that the
hospitals are committed to the 5 million
I think what you just said was CMS
understands what we're doing and they're
okay with that unwind but it's the are
the hospitals committed I don't have any
indication that I don't have a direct
indication that they aren't
um and we can double check with them if
you'd like haven't asked the question
they've complied they've you know
complied with their commitment
um all the other times so I have no
reason to believe that they won't all
so just to go back to that 24 change
column the reason you see that negative
3.9 million figure is because the
appropriation goes up by 1.1 million
to reflect that five percent of liquor
revenues will equal 11.1 rather than 10
is in the governor's budget
but then
the transfer from liquor revenues goes
down
by 5 million from that because of the
hospital's donation so there's a net
reduction in agency income of 3.9
sorry to be I mean this is the first
time I've seen this morning so
something I'm not that familiar with so
in the second year in 2025
you're anticipating no hospital donation
correct the last one will occur on or
before December 31st of this year and it
will all come out of the liquor fund yes
and
the the liquor fund has produced
you know
over 10 million in each of the most
recent years so
um
okay
right Mike please get it quote yeah
looks like
looks like in his comments to make he
keeps almost touching his microphone I'm
I'm just ready to go in case I need to
be that's all
okay you're sure okay
sorry
okay all right so go ahead so if you
move on to the next two pages these are
much more straightforward Amendment
0958h delete section 89
and 90 of the trailer bill
and that's a two million 54 000
appropriation for the recovery friendly
so we've discussed those two deletions
in the past as we've gone through hb2
saying if if we could clean up the way
the liquor fund money is flowing and the
way we're funding the granite state
Advantage Program have that transparent
then these two hb2 items become
redundant
so
so that completes the packet doesn't it
the the final amendment is 0.960h which
deletes section 99 which is 1.5 million
per year I believe
yes for Student Assistance programming
which is also an appropriation to the
governor's Commission
so now that you've seen those I would
now go back to the summary sheets on
page one unless there are questions do
you have a question here
what is the Student Assistance Program
Ming
is the question what is it what is it
what is the student assistance program
that is now losing one and a half
million per year I I would ask the
good morning for the record I'm Katya
Fox I'm the director of the division for
Behavioral Health
the um
if it's okay Mr chair I'd like to just
make a clarification on the
recommendations and the amendment that
deletes those provisions of hb2 just
because I want to point out that those
are with State fiscal year 23 funds so
we'll do that okay let's let's answer
representative I just I hit the floor
and I I wanted to take advantage of it
so I will be more direct
is a program that provides counselors in
schools to address substance misuse
among the student body but and it's
really considered to be primary
prevention so available to the whole
school but also for individual
situations
um
and it has been adopted across the state
by school districts they participate
they have a financial contribution
and make a local decision by their
school board to participate in the
program
and it I can get a list of schools but
so the schools have teeth in the game
here to participate and to maximize
their benefit of the program yes is it a
50 50 match or I believe it's 25 and
there are some circumstances if a school
district wants to join the program that
we consider that an available funding
so it may be lesson thank you
could I ask her
go ahead
so how long has this program been in
existence
I would need to get back to you on that
it's been
again I don't know the exact year it
started but it's a number of years and
why wouldn't it have shown up in the
budget
so it is has been funded through the
governor's commission and you wouldn't
normally see Appropriations to specific
programming you would just it would be
the governor's commission line in our
budget and they've made the decision to
support that program we also use block
grant so Federal block grant money
towards the program
so what does it mean if this program is
deleted
so this particular appropriation
um I just want to double check it and
may need to have
okay I'm going to try to answer that
I think what we wouldn't be deleting the
program we'd be deleting the hb2 item
that funds the program directly from the
the commission unentangled from these
other items the commission can do what
they've done in the past which is to
fund the program
because we've been borrowing money from
them we've
this hp2 item was there to replace some
of the money that we've been borrowing
from them for the granite state
Advantage Program
is that correct is that close
I'm not sure about the mechanics of that
but yes it does not change the funding
available to the program based on
Governor's commission actions and the
votes that they have taken this would
have been additive and it would have
so it's currently the commission
recently voted for its 20 State fiscal
year 24
Appropriations and it continues to
support this program at level funding
um and again this particular item won't
delete the program or eliminate the
program across the state it would have
expanded the program so that we could
Target middle schools as part of this
program
and and what is level funding
I do not have that right in front of me
um I I can get that back for you
it's multiple sources of funds so we
would need to go to the contract to find
to get that information
would this if we kept this wouldn't this
be the setting a precedent of being the
first time that we've used General funds
to basically pay for the Liquor
Commission programs or the alcohol and
drug abuse commission programs
I can't say whether or not it would be
the first time I think that funds were
General funds were appropriated to the
governor's commission versus the other
funds the from the liquor through the
alcohol so that's what I'm trying to
avoid is setting a new precedent that
and I would rather let the commission
have their all of their money the whole
five percent that they haven't been
getting and just let them make their
decisions on what their priorities are
representative thank you
um I was going to ask before we got to
that question about the um the ages of
the students who received this plan so
just to make sure I understand what you
just said
um without this the plan would not be
able to expand to the Middle School
level there
um thank you for that question there are
some schools that have it in the middle
school now this would allow us to
provide more support for additional
middle schools
could could the commission come back and
because we're giving them more of their
five percent
okay pay for the program expansion to
it's a decision they would make as a
group that would be up to the commission
right bacon they can choose but we're
trying to make sure they have the
additional resources so they can run
their programs that that that's that's
I guess not knowing a whole lot about
how the commission works is there
availability and flexibility in the
commission's budget to be able to
thank you for that because that does
point out that the commission has been
appropriated 10 million dollars with the
donations over the last several years
and the change to the five percent
as indicated by the LBA that's expected
to bump up the amount of available
dollars right now the commission has
been pretty diligent about appropriating
um and taking votes to fully expend the
amount of dollars they have it's a
non-lapsing account
um so they will have some flexibility on
to representative I'm I'm on that
commission as is Miss Fox and there it
feels like there's at least 30 if not 40
people representing a broad
cross-section of stakeholders throughout
the state all of them looking at the
Strategic function of the commission
which is to
prevent uh treat and support in any of
the negative consequences of alcohol or
drug abuse and so they've broken them
down into task forces the task forces
look at their areas and they come back
with budget recommendations so the
commission has a fairly disciplined
budget process within itself spending
their own money I I don't know if that's
more information than you wanted but if
you didn't know what the commission was
it should be a little more no that's
fine I just I have an interest in this
because of um
the New Hampshire Coalition of New
Hampshire prevention Coalition had
reached out to me about some funding
that they had presented to the
governor's budget office that they
didn't receive and I intend to
um submit an amendment to try to assist
those programs so I guess I'm trying to
wrap my brain around the big picture of
of where those resources are being
expended
are we through with the this package
well I did want to go through the rest
of the summary sheet
um go ahead so the first two lines on
the summary sheet are clear they
reference the amounts that will be saved
by deleting those two House Bill 2
sections
the third line uh reflects what would be
a surplus statement adjustment on the
legislature Surplus statement
that would reflect a five million dollar
savings in fiscal 24 by assuming that
the hospital's contribution would reduce
the transfer from liquor by five million
dollars
finally
because
granted Advantage would no longer
receive liquor funds through the alcohol
fund that that program would need a
direct injection of liquor funds
so that would be reflected on the
Surplus statement as an 11 million
dollar cost in fiscal 24. the reason
we're only showing that in 24 is because
as you know as of now granted Advantage
is only real is only authorized through
the end of this fiscal year if it were
reauthorized there would need to be
another 11 million dollar cost on the
Surplus statement in fiscal 25. but for
The house's current purposes it would be
a single 11 million dollar hit
so the net result if the committee were
to adopt all of these changes would be a
cost of roughly a million dollars over
okay so this is too much to digest in
just one thing so I I propose that
um we we caucus on this in that we come
back and we vote on the package and if
the package doesn't succeed then we
figure out which are the components that
we can support
representative norgren okay one question
uh representative Stringham um the the
um no longer funding Granite State
advantage through the alcohol fund
um does that revert back if it's
reinstated or is this meant to be a
permanent change
and
this is meant to be a permanent change
but granted Advantage would still be any
shortfall in granted Advantage would
still be funded with liquor funds that's
current law so they just wouldn't pass
through the governor's commission first
so instead go to the general fund and
then transfer over is that uh liquor
funds would transfer to granted
Advantage before going into the general
fund thank you it also depends
on what happens with the Bradley Bill to
do Granite State Advantage extension
right he's got three sources of funds
that open up the transparency for
funding the the that Medicaid expansion
program so if that law passes then I
think the answer is a little different
than the one Mr Ripple just gave it's
actually the same because Senate Bill
263 has amended by the Senate actually
does
what you're trying to do here in 0974h
it allows the alcohol fund to keep that
five percent of liquor profits without
all right so
let's talk about Medicaid
um is there do we have a sheet that
shows us
um
recommendations on medic targeted
Medicaid rates we there we got one from
Mr Monahan
um what what what did you intend for us
I have not printed out that sheet but I
can I can do so if you'd like to talk
about that now well I I think that's why
Mr Lipman is here he's still here to
talk about Medicaid I believe and if we
can front load these discussions so that
he feels comfortable even if he needs to
Miss Horgan does does that have that
foreign
okay so while he's making the copies I'm
I'm going to tell the back story on on
on some of what's been taking place
everyone here knows that the governor is
supporting a 3.1 percent Medicaid
reimbursement increase across the board
there's a 17 million dollar line item
that that feeds that 3.1 percent
simultaneously
dealing with the bill introduced
initially by Senator Rosenwald that said
that that 17 million isn't enough we
need to come up with 145 million more
over the two years
there was the senator Bradley amendment
to that and what appears to be in strong
position in the Senate
is a proposal to spend 40 in each of the
two years so instead of 145 I think the
Bradley proposals at 80. for the two
years
so
that's what's going on there what what
Mr Moynihan has done for us is he's
coordinated with a number of
stakeholders throughout our community
rely on Medicaid reimbursement rates
and uh he asked them uh I guess these
were interactive meetings but he asked
them to
identify a targeted rate increase it
wasn't a rate increase but a targeted
amount of money that would keep them
whole that that would keep them from
basically shutting down in the next two
years is the proposal is meant to be a
minimum essential need request to sort
of keep them going and if I say this
wrong Miss Horgan you you're you know we
have my permission to correct me am I
right so far
okay thank you so uh so what this
spreadsheet does is it it takes sort of
a collective wisdom of our Medicaid
providers and informs us what they think
they need to basically stay in business
so in the long-term care area the
nursing homes the the notes talk about a
15 rate increase
and that translates into 16.5 million
dollars in each of the two years that so
that that's that's kind of an overall
explanation of this spreadsheet and then
that process and the notes are repeated
throughout this spreadsheet
um and they get to the bottom line
which they uh it's basically a hundred
hundred and technically it's a hundred
Point fifty five and
98.95 for the two years but it's easier
for me to think of it as a hundred
hundred
um and
um and so so this is their re this is
their request
I think we've been open to the idea of
providing some additional assistance to
our to our Medicaid providers
um the but the but this begins to make
us think about exactly how much and
where and how and so so this this will
be the first time I think we've had this
level of conversation but I think so far
we've been aligned on the idea that we
need to do something
does does anyone disagree with that
summary there that we have to do
something right the question is how much
and where
representative norgren do you have a
comment there or representative Waller
Wallner
this and and thank you and I'm so sorry
had we not had that snowstorm you you'd
already been out in front on this well I
I was glad to spend a lot of time on
this chart the day we were we were
getting snowed in so uh and although
um
we could spend months digging into the
details but before kind of going into
um you know which which areas might have
higher priority I think I think it might
be useful just to talk about where the
3.1 percent came from
and um uh and why that's uh not an
adequate number and maybe
um we could uh you know win the 3.1
percent was originally developed uh a
lot of the current inflation figures
weren't available and
um
um you know maybe we could just kind of
start with that but if we just did
inflation itself do you want to start
with it or do you want Mr lippman to do
that I would love Mr lippman to do it
and then I could comment on it do you
understand the request give us the
history on the 3.1 yes we had a very
brief conversation ahead of the meeting
here uh you know in terms of the budget
process
we're almost like a year prior to you
starting to really hone in on
information when we're sort of
developing our numbers and I think
inflation has taken off the Staffing
situations that Health Care Providers as
uh
Gone Gone worse not better you know the
the length of time which
hospitals and other home care
agencies and the like nursing homes have
had to to deal with uh the the
consequences of working through the the
infection issues that have affected us
and the impacts on that
um I think we were swamped by by that
and what we did in developing our budget
was to look at trying to be at the time
be reasonable based on what something
that the legislature previously had an
appetite to to support and that was the
the 3.1 percent
um
came from and that was consistent with
what was done in 20 uh January of 20 and
21.
but I think you know we I think factors
have swamped us since then
yeah and I think you you uh you you
mentioned that uh a couple of times the
inflation index have been
um revised at least your perception of
that since since the 3.1 percent was
done right and um and that the 145
million uh increase was based on what 11
was that correct
representative could you please bring
your microphone closer and talk into it
I think people yeah I'll I'll try to eat
it so the um uh I think the
um my my question was the um uh the uh
instead of the 34 million if you used a
rate of 11
uh you were dealing with something
closer to 145 or 150 million is that
correct from the Rosenwald uh bill
Senate Bill 86 as introduced at 145
million over the biennium and that
equated using 22 numbers to 11 increase
on on services so applying that all
those dollars to Services resulted in 11
increase and that was a number we
developed with our actuary
foreign okay so is it fair to assume uh
that
um uh if we provided the same mix of
services and all the service codes
and used two years ago as a base and
then to now whether we used 11 no change
in in service mix
um that uh you know basically all those
Services would be similarly uh stressed
or or provided
I'm not sure I followed you all the way
through I apologize um
if you could just pass that out just a
little bit more well I I guess I'm just
saying with an 11 11 increase based on
these new numbers right
um and that uh
uh and I'm not saying that whether those
amount of funding is adequate or not
adequate or overly adequate but we would
just have kind of the same balance of
um uh at that at that point we would be
providing the same number of services
within each of the benefit categories
and so on and I hope that's helpful I
think I think that's
I think in using 22 right we have
enrollment that's elevated currently
using 22 numbers so I think that uh on a
net basis we we might expect and we
would hope that some of the care that's
not being delivered as a function of not
having enough staff would probably
come into play but the fact that we'd
have lower enrollment would make that
that adequate I mean not adequate but
fall within that number
and so you're saying you're going to
have lower enrollment in the next two
years than you've had in these two years
correct because of the end of continuous
enrollment
and and what's the rough you have a
rough figure for that yes so
um
pre
um Federal action we're at about 178 000
total enrollment today we're just over
250 000. we are estimating based on our
um on unwind uh plan that that will
generate just itself approximately 60
000 reduction and then sort of just the
normal course of over the the next
following year we expect to start to
approach
um you know where we were you know
economic circumstances I think somewhere
between 178 and 190 is probably you know
a pretty reasonable settling Point based
on what we understand
so when you were providing some of this
summary tables and I think was roughly
555 million of
uh funds from the general funds to fund
the Medicaid Program you were basing
that on 2018 and the reason for that is
is that related to this because you
think the numbers are more equivalent to
where we were in 2000 I think it was 18.
um so when we
we were doing the sort of the fiscal
analysis for
um the the proposed 145 million over the
biennium we looked at two years we
looked at calendar 19 because that was a
year that was completed before any covid
considerations would have to be made and
then we looked at 22 our state fiscal
year 22. so we kind of developed sort of
a range and they're within two percent
of each other in terms of what the the
expectation is you know certain services
have suppressed other services you know
um
have continued so it's it's seeing those
services that come back that uh
um you know our budget numbers also
reflect
um you know medical inflation of three
percent in in what we propose to you in
the um the agency and I think the
governor's phase there
I just want to do a time check here
because I've been told that the
Democrats have a caucus at some point
that's coming up very soon
at noon okay all right keep going
so by three percent medical inflation is
that uh Could you
um Define that for us so that would be
things like new
um
drugs or therapies
that would reflect
um
you know we're going to see potentially
the people who will leave the program
will be generally have lower lower
Acuity or will have lower Acuity than
those that remain and so there's a
factor there you know basically
um we've been able to manage the program
with
um
focusing on quality and utilization to
kind of be beat inflation if you will in
terms of medical inflation anyways but
that's you know we do we do practically
do see some that we can't overcome
through those factors each year so
that's that's where the three percent
comes from
so I I just want to go back to my my my
planning boundary conditions around this
so that people know where I'm coming
from and they can just disagree or agree
with this direction
what I think we ought to do is just take
the 3.1 percent as the floor the the
base
and then do a targeted rate increase
and then the question is questions
become how much
I've answered that question by saying 40
million per year because that's
consistent with what the Senate seems to
be coming up with and I I just soon aim
at what they may be aiming at
and then this proposal from Monahan
um and the and the community is an
opportunity for us to discuss how to
allocate it or spread it now you and I
have not had an opportunity to discuss
this
because I I don't know what sort of work
product that you may have been
developing for us because you've been
working this project for a while to
recommend targeted rate increases and so
I I'm just curious if this sheet from Mr
Monahan is useful to what you were
working on or do you have something
um first of all I do think it's it's
very useful
um I do think I do agree that the issue
of how much
how much needs to go for overall
um
uh you know to the Medicaid Program from
General funds uh is an issue
um you know where I am based on what
I've seen
um 17 and 40 per year is not enough
so
um this sheet that minahan provided
still doesn't cover durable medical
equipment or Pharmacy which are two
additional benefit categories that
probably are going to need something
and um uh
and you know I think I think even even
114 doesn't get us a system
delivering the same
uh same amount as we are right now I do
think these allocations and you know I
think the governor challenged us to
maybe have priorities that's that's kind
of a separate discussion but um uh you
know I I think targeting 200 is is a a
better way to go is probably going to
get us uh some some better services for
for our citizens okay so
um I just want to clean up a a a a a a
factoid
the 17 million is the base this 40 would
be on top of it so if we did both it
would be 57. 114 for two years
114 for two years right
57 and 57. yeah so so
um so maybe
maybe rather than discussing the
debating the dollar amount whether it
should be this 57 per year or 145 or 200
rather than debating that right now
would we make any progress if we could
at least identify
the um
those items that we would want to Target
within increases would you would you
would you think that we should continue
to Target or attempt to Target or
would you just take your 200 for example
and continue to spread it evenly
well I I think it's important to look at
the line items so that we understand why
the need is there
um
you know I I don't know how how much uh
as a group will want to direct
um the department uh to specific uh
codes and and benefit categories
um but I do think it's important for us
to discuss why some of them may have
more impact on our citizen citizenry
than others but
well I really think we should use the um
information that was provided to us by
the provider groups I mean they know
their services and they know
better than we do what what they need in
order to stay viable
um and so I would want to use this as as
a guide guide for how we do it I
um don't have any way of myself making
decisions about whether one
service is worthy more than another
service
but it seems to me that
you know the three percent is just way
too low that that just does not work
um
the 11 percent
is
you know even even from the time that we
filed legislation
a lot has happened
and I think the providers have provided
us with the information of what they
really feel they need
and I would use that as my guidance
representative Weiler
I might have missed something at the
beginning but is this a proposal we're
looking at all new money or Does it
include present rates or Does it include
the 3.1 percent or what is it all just
I'm going to look to miss Horgan to
shake her head I I think this is uh
incremental money assuming the 3.1
percent is uh is implemented
yes
thank you
representative I just wanted to add that
um I found this document extremely
um educational
and
um the fact that the hospitals
are seeing the value of passing at
minimum their three percent
on to others uh in particular Community
providers with emphasis on long-term
care and mental health I think that
speaks volumes to the task at hand here
that
not everything is equal it's not Apples
to Apples and the the industry and the
players have identified that and so I
would hope that we could take that as
guidance and invest in the areas that
will
um also benefit
um the hospitals and and other people
who have decided to or have
suggested that we forgo their three
percent or more I'm gonna Echo your
compliment to the hospital Association
but I just want to clarify a granular
element of it and that is
um since this document is meant to be
incremental above the 3.1 percent I I
think there the hospital is is expecting
their 3.1 percent
but this would be so they don't even
so so when we first said this was all
incremental assuming the 3.1 percent was
implemented this is actually an
well okay so so my question there is
of the hospital allocation of the 3.1
percent how many dollars is that
go ahead Nathan I want to know right now
what what is 3.1 percent of the hospital
share
uh in dollar amounts
I I know that's going to take his time
I'm just joking a little bit but but
thank you because I I didn't assume that
I I thought it was Noble that they were
looking to spread the wealth but go
ahead well I I understood when I looked
at this they were looking to spread the
wealth of their 3.1 percent that was
being allocated to them and you were
right I I just have never known any
entity ever forgo money and that is why
I wanted to point it out was that
they're looking at the big picture and
the overall
um the whole environment of Health Care
here in the state and how to better
provide care
Mr chairman go ahead representative
according to page uh I think it's 50
from last page of our division of
Medicaid services hospital inpatient was
130 million including Granite State on
Hospital outpatient is 213 million for a
total of 343 million
6.1 percent would be about 9 million uh
I believe so um so that's fee for
service and Managed Care Medicare I'm
sorry those were those
out of about you know roughly 2 billion
of totals I think we have and the answer
is
foreign
confirming representative bringham
strength sorry is the 130 and the 213
was was the correct numbers for
um 2022 2022
and so um I'll just do the 3.1 percent
on that in a second here
so
um you know the hospitals aren't being
entirely
um uh generous
just just just to be nice or to make the
system work better they're they're being
financially
um damaged by having to have patients
stay in the hospital use up a bed get no
money for it virtually and not be able
to bring in a paying patient
so
um uh because uh in particular I think
their testimony was that that two other
systems the nursing home system and the
Home Health Care home health aid type
systems weren't robust enough for them
to operate at full efficiency so they're
saying uh
um if you help them you'll be helping us
and
um why that why any money that would be
available to them would still come to
them if you give it to these other
sources so
um
uh
you know with with the uh amount of
funds that we have about available uh
you know they've done a great service to
point us in the in those directions
so
I I preferred the fantasy they were
being Noble but thank you for reality uh
Mr Lemon do you have a number four 10.6
million 10.6 million 10.6
Okay so
so just just to keep my numbers
consistent
per year if if they're with that 10.6
plus the 40 million
then just the add-on I think that we
could do within this spreadsheet I I
would aim at
50.6 million and and you're
probably four times greater than that so
but but I just I just wanted to at least
tell you what that did to my numbers
no no I I'm I would still I would add
the 17 million to that 50.6 million I'm
not I haven't been adding it okay I'm
not interested in adding it really
because the 17 million is already
assumed to be in there we're not we're
not debating
the 17's in there unless well wait a
second let me let me the let me tell you
what we would have to take the hospitals
go ahead if if we had 100 million per
year
with 17 million would come from the
amount that's already in hb2
so we have another 40 million this is
another 10. so we're looking for another
well you wouldn't have the seven total
17 if you're other if you double time
the 10.6 you have the 17 as well right
the 10.6 subtracts from the 17 doesn't
it
I think what I'm trying to explore is if
that 10.6 from the hospital would is
part of that 17 million
right and so Mr Ripple shaking has said
yes
that's my understanding I think if you
were to take out the 10.6 million for my
understanding is that the 10.6 million
is included in that 17 figure so if you
did not want to provide the 3.1 percent
to hospitals that 17 could come down to
6.4
go ahead Mr lippman
so I guess one other
um tweak here is that the while the 130
and the 213 is correct the the granite
Advantage component wouldn't be in that
that
um that's another sub-calculation that
we need to make here
and just to confirm since I'm not
looking at that page in the handout I
don't have it up in front of me that
combined 343 million from which you got
the 10.6 that's all General funds that
that was just basing it off the total
you know going back to my sheet
clicked in we also have to factor that
the
I should give you a different run
another number here while I'm sitting
here that that takes into account that
that would be funded through the other
mechanism was considered earlier today
which is the the different sources okay
representative walner thank you this is
sort of a question that takes me at
least back to square one
how much total
general fund is spent
on Medicaid providers the total of
General funds
my answer would come from a an email
that Mr Littman provided I can try to
find that and print that out for the
committee
I think he is using go just I think
adjusting for the fact that granted
Advantage funding for those Services
would come through the other funding
mechanism it's probably closer to 5
million that would be the
um the impact on this the 17 because
none of that 17 was funding
so could I go back maybe Mr lichmann's
got the figure
how much General funds
is used for Medicaid
providers total
all providers
sure so what we have included in the
governor's recommended budget
um in for standard Medicaid 7940a class
101 is approximately 751 million in the
first year and 760 million dollars total
funds in the second year
um there is also the uh the chip program
and that total is 113 roughly 113
million and say fiscal year 24 and
114.5 million in state fiscal year 25
total funds
now each of those standard Medicaid has
50 50 chip is 65 35 so there's there's
differentials on on the federal and
general fund amounts
and are the figures you're giving me
including
nursing homes home health aide all of
the Medicaid all of the Medicaid
services
so that's that's a you know there's an
additional number here and Kevin has a
copy of what we had provided to him
um
in 22
the state share
was 658 million
um
for
excluding granted advantage
and the state share with granted
advantage in 22
excuse me the non-federal share in 22
for granted Advantage was 36
million and I think Kevin just went out
to print
that page for you great thank you but
but representative Wallner just to
clarify
um what's not included in those numbers
total General funds
used as the match for all Medicaid
services
and maybe um maybe I'm stating stating
it incorrectly but that's I'm looking
for what are we totally using of General
funds to match all Medicaid services so
the number I mentions the 658 includes
all services not just what's in the
division that provides the health
insurance component includes the waivers
and everything everything
if I could uh just um
in we work with our actuary on those
numbers and because of the time that the
governor's
um
talked about uh funding Services it does
the number I just gave you looking at
the footnote from the actuary excludes
Pharmacy and and DME so that would be an
additional piece I'd have to get to add
to that that number
say again the two things that excluded
and if you could just get them pull the
so the
um when we ran the numbers that I just
quoted they excluded things that weren't
Services durable medical equipment is a
is a good if you will and Pharmacy is a
is a good so we had not
included those and and so the number
that Kevin just passed out you'll see on
that
so unfortunately the printer is not
working I did I did send this to em this
email to everyone if they have access to
email so otherwise it might be a might
be a couple more a couple minutes before
I can hand that out do you have an
estimate representative stream since
you've been playing with Pharmacy and
durable goods you you think you know a
ballpark for either of those the
ballpark for DME is 23 million 230 38
and 959 no just do round numbers you
break my brain If you 23 million and 290
million for pharmacy DME 23 million so
an extra 323 million between those two
items about plus 658 so we're tickling a
billion I'm sorry those are full
expenditures I could cut those in half
okay
um so that's so we're like 8.75 General
funds somewhere in that neighborhood I
think that's what we're trying to answer
your question with representative walner
875 in that neighborhood
it'd be nice to have all this in writing
it it would it would and I don't think
we're going to vote on this today I I
get that but I would like to see it all
in writing yeah yeah Kevin did send it
an email I just got it an email
so what was the real answer just the
well the answer I've been out in and out
of the room but I think I heard Mr
Lipman mentioned the two numbers that
are shown here at the low end based on
calendar year 19 uh the state share of
Medicaid costs for providers was about
556 million and at the high end based on
fiscal 22 it was 658 million
Plus Pharmacy Plus DME correct okay so
so does your email add those
it does not okay all right
okay
so I assume that you wanted to know the
875 number or whatever it is 850 880
whatever that number is you're looking
to
um Baseline how much additional you
think we ought to be doing is that the
purpose of that number for you
well I just hit heard you saying that
you thought the bill that Senator
Rosenwald brought brought in was around
11 and I just wanted to see and I see
that
um Kevin actually sent us some of that
okay so
um I think we got going back to what
items that we want to Target I think we
may have agreement that the sheet that
Mr Moynihan provided
um is a good list of line items for us
to consider and with the addition of two
other line items I've heard
representative Stringham say that
there's nothing about Pharmacy and we
ought to consider Pharmacy as well as
the durable medical items that maybe
some money needs to be allocated to that
as well okay so so I'd kind of like to
go through an exercise where we where we
talk about these uh line items
sort of in a kind of relative context to
each other
and I don't know I don't know how we're
going to end up voting on this on Monday
but but I do think there's a discussion
that we can have on these items
um the the
I I'll I'll start by saying what I think
the critical problem is that we must
solve in this budget or at least try to
mitigate to a very large extent and that
is we have to give the hospitals an
opportunity to have capacity that they
can discharge into
so of the items on here that I would
prioritize my first priority would be
any capacity beyond the hospital walls
that would support their ability to
discharge and and have that patient
received properly so that would increase
funding for things like the long-term
care line the CFI home line
um
and those are those would be the two
primary lines I see for creating
capacity for discharge
we could talk about input also to reduce
the number of admissions but first I'd
solve the discharge problem
representative tolersky I just had a
question and I appreciate going line by
line but I think Ms Horgan might be able
to help I'm a little concerned about the
um to be announced next to home health
aids
um because I see that as a as a way to
discharge
um people also is to have that
that service and I don't know if there's
okay
you have something you should be saying
into a microphone
do you have something we should repeat
for you then
what did what did you just said that
they she does not have any information
yet on home health aids and what that
oh so you're you're looking under the
big category of state plan home health
and then the Top Line home health aids
under detailed requests TBA you want to
know more detail I just I picture that
as a way to discharge patients also to a
home situation and to be able to have
that kind of assistance at home so I was
wondering what that number was in a
general Factor since it's a zero right
now I think I agree with you and that's
an excellent question
thank you so without without input from
from a provider I would suggest if we
end up digging into the line that we use
what the existing budget is uh case
management loads and see what
um you know 12 increase would would
bring it to if it's or maybe 15 since
it's similar to nursing homes so I just
want to remind us of where we are in the
space-time Continuum we we have to vote
on a a documented amendment to hb1 and
hb2 those votes ought to be done what no
later than Tuesday Mr Ripple
Tuesday yes so so anytime we say we have
some homework or we have another person
we need to bring in or anything like
that it we start to run into the the
wall of impracticality that that so so
so so so let's let's say representative
100 right and it would be wise to
support the home health aids number
in the in the in the lack of in the
absence of some kind of of better
information
I've gotten really comfortable in a
budgeting cycle of using Wags our best
wild ass to to get into the ballpark
right and as long as we're using some
judgment and and all we we would do
better than just doing nothing so zero
percent of a TBA is too low so we ought
to do I just want to make sure that we
don't it doesn't get lost in the shuffle
and I wanted to clarify that we had no
more information at this point so that
we can take a somewhat I that's your
term sir yeah yeah go ahead represent
Weiler
I I would have to go back to the numbers
to determine that amount but I can get
that for you but but I think to the
broader Point these are distinct we have
CFI and then we have a different issue
related to the stone estate plan Home
Health with home health aids they are
not the same yes right
right but we just don't know the dollar
amount
yeah I I think we would need to go back
and look at the details because because
we're really talking about a lot of very
detailed things here and in Broad ways
and I I think if we can maybe just kind
of step back and get some detail
together that may be best for the
committee just to have informed
discussions
oh okay so so that's my first proposal
just in as a principle is that we fund
discharge capacity
so then the other end of that systems
view is what can we do to reduce
the inputs the patients flowing into the
hospitals that would be kind of my
secondary investment priority to try to
do the things we can in the community to
preclude or to to mitigate the number of
admissions that are taking place
so and so in that line
uh things like the community health
outpatient services might have already
been needed but but so so those
Community Health Center Services would
get a priority for me for trying to
reduce the amount of inpatients that go
to the hospital to begin with is there
I saw a thumbs up representative norgren
you like the principles so far we got
priority one priority two representative
walner
well I think there are other things that
I mean
substance use disorder I mean
opioid treatment programs I mean if we
treat people before they end up with
serious health issues
going to keep them out of the hospitals
and if that's your I mean to me
yes keeping people out of the hospitals
is
an excellent goal but a lot of these
other services keep people from going
into higher higher levels of care I mean
for instance the DD population
if these Services aren't available for
them
they end up needing institutionalization
so much more than if we were providing
the services to them in their homes
um
say same with the mental health centers
if we don't do this work in the
community
we're going to end up
with
New Hampshire hop and needing more
inpatient
New Hampshire hospital type Services
Hampstead Hospital I mean all of these
all of these lead a lot of these prevent
us from having to have higher end
services
I
I don't really disagree with what you
what you just said I I
I'm trying to take a look at this from a
narrower
prioritize basis
and
um I I and maybe I don't know the Ed
warehousing problem boarding I guess is
the word Edie boarding issue well enough
but I don't imagine that
the patients that are being subjected to
Ed boarding
have a high correlation with the DD
community
so so I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm just telling
you my assumption I don't know if that's
right or not that's my assumption that
the DD Community is not being brought in
to the Ed
boarding problem
and my first goal
is to Let's solve the Ed boarding
problem as our first priority with the
extra money
not that there aren't other priorities
not that there aren't other goals but if
we're going to
take limited resources we ought to try
to focus it to have the most significant
impact on the biggest problem that we
I was just going to comment that I think
there was a connection made there that
wasn't exactly a direct line
and I believe representative walner was
simply pointing out that funding a
certain
group align items here that that
helps the hospital flow for the
Emergency Department boarding crisis
which you pointed to
that actually is not
Direct that's not connected at all with
the developmental disability community
and representative wallner's point was
simply that if we don't
um
fund
these AIDS and services and all the
people that showed up at the budget
hearing
um particularly the family with the two
grown sons in their 20s and the mother
who is their sole caregiver and needs
surgery but can't get surgery because
she has no caregivers if we don't fund
that Community the alternative is we're
going to have to pay for these men to go
live in a nursing home which is going to
cost the state so much more so there's
no connection to the emergency
department boarding so much as
the costs that we will bear
by pushing this group which is so high I
forgive me that I don't have it in front
of me 35 million for the DD and brain
injury Community if we don't deal with
that then we are going to be paying a
much bigger price tag
for these people that have to get moved
to a nursing home or an institution
would you believe I agree with
everything you just said and everything
that representative Wallner said
but I'm not sure that you I've
communicated the process I'm trying to
to follow I'm trying to solve one
strategic problem well and then when we
think we know how to address that
strategic problem we can go to a second
strategic problem
and and do this in some sort of a
prioritized basis because we have
limited resources and unlimited once and
so
I appreciate that approach yeah
I guess I don't agree that it's a black
and white draw line situation
by the time we walk through all of the
goals
it's no longer black and white it's a
beautiful Mosaic of a comprehensive
puzzle
but you gotta like in my experience
having done this for 40 years you you
need you need to focus on particular
issues solve them before you go on to
the next one and you do that in a
prioritized basis so
um
it's because if we don't have if we
don't have some sort of guide the
guidelines or guide rails on our
conversations we'll just end up going
all over the place every single time you
know it will you know
which maybe we should just do that I
think the Senate's approach was let's
just give the department the money and
let them figure it out I'm I'm trying to
have us
be a little bit more judicious and give
a little bit more guidance to the
department to say here are the
legislative priorities but if we can't
have that discussion then we'll have to
do what the Senate is going to do and
this is here's the money go spend it the
way you want representative I totally
agree that I appreciate this
conversation and the way we're going I
think this is the right way to go I was
just simply questioning a connection
yeah that was made and I want just want
to make sure that we are not forgetting
the biggest piece of this puzzle here in
terms of of funds that's it we can move
on it's okay so so we'll we'll actually
jump I think now maybe not because it's
the right order but it's become the
right order I I think we had a different
approach on the DD community
that we found Let's see we found that in
the DD community
there is currently a huge lapse that we
can discuss a carry forward on and so
this line item on the DD and brain
injury is its own strategic problem but
it may also have its own
potential resources available to solving
it that that deity and brain injury line
and and Mr Ripple and Mr lippman is gone
so Mr White I'll turn to you but it's my
understanding that of that for that 35
35 there's a current
amount of about 60 million or is it 80
million I'll I'll let you correct me but
there's a fairly large amount of money
that's set to lapse that we could roll
forward to pay at least pay down that
35. sure so the acquired brain disorder
account the DD Services account and then
the children's IHS account those are all
continually appropriate and non-lapsing
um and so there's a provision section
232 in hb2 that would allow us
explicitly to carry those funds forward
we had based our our budget on the
assumption that those funds would be
carried forward in accordance with the
law to be used for services provided in
in 24 for existing for existing clients
so I I guess just to bring us back to
this document and maybe this is a Ms
Horgan head shake uh question uh does
this does this incremental 35 million in
a year for the DD and brain injury line
did that anticipate that there was
already money that was going to non-laps
and carry forward into the next fiscal
year
got it
all right
Edwards just
um just to muddy this up a little bit
but I think it's important is what we're
talking about
um is not just the budget but what were
the rate increases be if somebody's
getting paid 14 an hour and it's built
in to the Medicaid fee schedule
um if you increase that amount by three
percent it's a relatively small amount
for a home health aide or whatever rate
that represents
um you know uh so you know somebody
still has to do the work to get to get
these uh these monies and I think you
know you made a very
um uh an important observation in the
beginning uh when we started this
process that uh if we increase the rates
enough you know maybe the vacancies will
go down the amount of services we
provide might go up a bit because
there's a lot of untapped need the way
we control the budget is um by as uh
unfortunately is by having such low
rates that uh the people that are
eligible for the service often don't get
it so we spend less so
um really really what this 18 I think
that the disability Community is asking
for is a change in the rates
for the services that they provide and
it's not divided out there's probably 40
different uh service codes that they
have they just they just gave us one
across the entire
um uh benefit benefit category so
um
you know everything else that we're
going to have to assume is that it
doesn't impact utilization and we we may
may want to think about I mean obviously
the goal of boosting
um long-term care for example is to
increase utilization so more of those
people get out of the hospital so
um
uh I think we just kind of need to keep
you're you're playing chess I'm playing
checkers my checker game right now is
just simply uh deferring how much new
money we're going to put into this and
trying to figure out what
categories
are relatively important and prioritized
and how we might solve them okay you're
sort of at the next level which once we
decide that
how do we implement it how do we turn
that in and that's where Mr Ripple comes
in with Mr lippman and Mr White how do
we turn that extra money into something
actionable whether it's increased pay
raises or I don't know
I
I I'm I'm I'm operating in a more
um
okay so I I think
I'm still trying to figure out because I
thought in our
caucus that we understood uh this deity
and brain injury line item that they're
asking for 35 million per year
and that incremental amount that
explains why but irrespective the answer
is 35 million
um that that could be supported by the
current amount that could be carried
over without the lapse you thank you for
the correction on the language it's not
going to lapse but it's still a surplus
that can carry over into the next year
yes our our our initial agency budget
and the conversations that we had during
the governor's phase of the budget we we
based our figures at that time our in
class 7100 are spend figures on the
assumption that we would have those
carry forward funds available
at that time
so so this is yet still another 35
million without regard to the amount of
surplus it's in the current year
it's it's a it's a function of the fact
that that that these counts are
continually appropriated and non-lapsing
all right I I I know but you I don't
know if you even looking at what we're
looking at we're looking at Mr Monahan's
spreadsheet Oh Oh I thought where where
they've said they need 35 million a year
for the next two years and they explain
why yep and I'm I and I had until today
thought that that 35 million a year
could be satisfied largely if not
entirely by the amount of money that's
in the current year that's being carried
into the next that's why I asked Mrs
Horgan if she knew
if that 35 million was
based on knowing
the carryover was going to take place or
if that was yet intended to be
incremental money still I understood no
so so I I would assume just just looking
at this that that this would be an
increase above the current amounts that
are budgeted okay so the bottom line is
I can't count on the carryover in the
current budget to address any of this 35
million is that is that your conclusion
if
you guys don't like conclusion
statements right like yes no we we don't
do yes no's
um so if if you were to reduce the
service levels you would assume that
those Services wouldn't be provided
um or that there wouldn't be providers
in the community to be able to provide
those Services I think that's there is a
requirement under 171a that requires the
legislature and and the agency when we
submit our budget to fully fund the
those those services so that's I I just
want to put that out there
do you understand what he's saying no
okay here's what he's saying they're
required by law to fully fund all the
services even knowing there's no way
they're going to be able to deliver all
those services
so the reality is there is there are
funds there that could be put into work
at other places where the services can
be funded for instance in the nursing
homes so we need to be a little careful
about that whole thing you know I might
suggest and I don't want to end up your
flow here but we have a big list here
some of these things might be easy and I
understand Mr lipman's here today I get
that but he might be able to come back
again at a later point in time because
there might be some things we could just
like tick off of here perhaps because
this is a this clearly is like I would
say the last
once we in my opinion once we've
addressed everything else we'll have an
idea where we stand in terms of funds
and we can then go and say okay now how
do we do this
how do we decide to give it to them to
handle it as maybe Mr Singham
believes or try to design it ourselves
or whatever but this is obviously a huge
problem this this Monahan thing it is
and so what my intent was here was to to
fully get it out there because we're not
going to agree I know at the end of the
day we're not going to agree so so I
want to make it so that everyone is
clear enough on the information so they
can everyone can go caucus and and
figure out the two big questions which
is how much money and and are we going
to Target it or not and if we target it
you know so so I'm just trying to get
enough discussion out there to put that
canoe in the water so we can come back
on Monday and find the extent to which
we disagree
I think you've done a good job of that
okay all right I'm really really good at
learning how to disagree with people
that's my strong point this week so
um okay uh
so what other of these line items did we
talk about you know like for example
where they oh go ahead represent a
Stringham I just want to talk about one
that uh it would definitely be a high
priority for me and that is the
ambulance uh Service rates uh we've lost
three ambulance providers since uh we
first met as a group uh bethlehem's uh
Ambulance Service shut down in the last
three weeks a major uh Ambulance Company
went out of business in January and
Laconia stopped servicing and um uh the
the rates are a big part of the problem
for that the way I looked at it I
actually went down to the individual
service codes and I have have
recommendations that are somewhat above
the Medicare rates
but we'd be looking at a couple of
million dollars to maybe boost up that
system a bit so let's talk about that a
moment I in when I Point thought I had
40 million to spread across the 100
million in requests I've fully funded
the ambulance because I I you know if
you can't get people from point A to
point B it doesn't matter what kind of
capacity you're building so
um I I I am in a line with um with you
and I was just going to put the 2.2 in
there uh per year
um and figure out how to allocate the
rest of it so I I you I mean you still
have your caucus uh but uh the
Republican caucus when we talked about
this seemed like we were okay funding
that ambulance service right okay so so
so if you if you have some details that
you want to like start flushing out I I
think it'd be fine for you to start
talking to you know Mr Ripple because
I can do that
you have any disagreement with that no
okay
I'm sort of all over the place and I had
such a methodical way of doing this
initially
I I don't think we know what we need to
know about the DD and brain injury money
so because I think you've been looking
at this and you're tying it in with a
county cap
I'll I'll let you talk about it well I
don't need to talk about that what I'll
say is this
I don't think we need to concern
ourselves with the DD money you mean
you're talking about the money that's
lapsing or not lapsing but rolling over
from this current biennium and the
perhaps excess money that's built into
the budget because it's fully funded for
services that won't be rendered those
are dollars that need to be decided
about how they're going to be allocated
along with other places we're going to
find dollars I I think if we can get
through the majority of this list
which Mr Ripple handed out at the very
beginning before we get to I mean you've
done a good I I I'm glad you did what
you did in terms of the Monahan thing
but I think we all kind of I think on
both sides of the aisle so to speak we
have an idea of the issues if you can
indulge me for five more minutes I think
that I can come off of this spreadsheet
all together well that's fine did you
understand where I was going though in
terms of yeah we're going to go back to
the full H well no but my tent was to
point out that what we're talking about
with the Monahan thing is how many
dollars do we have and how do we
allocate okay so one of the to answer
the Muhammad dollars we have apart we
could get through this and then we'd
have it because if we have like a
bazillion dollars we can all just say
hey let's just go wild
but if we only have Brazilian dollars
but if we have something less than a
bazillion you know then we'll have their
conversation about how we divvy it up
all right so so just to finish this
spreadsheet community health centers in
the rebasing and rate adjustment they
they want six and six for the rebasing
and and I and what I understand that to
be is that over time our Medicaid
payment framework gets a little further
and further out of alignment with where
it should be relative to Medicare and so
rebasing it is would throw some more
money just into the Medicaid
reimbursement framework to get things
back where they
ought to have been if we hadn't been
spreading out over time
so so I I think so much of our problem
in the state is our Medicaid
reimbursements are so low that it
creates dysfunction that then just gets
Amplified throughout the health system
so I would like to try to fix the
Medicaid system a little bit more this
rebasing would be fundamental to doing
that so I I would prioritize the 6
million for the rebasing and they asked
for 4 million in a rate adjustment that
I I'm not sure how that fits in with the
overall issue but and then on the
midwives this is such a tiny amount of
money and we lost that birthing center
up north and I I would just I would just
agree I would spend the hundred thousand
on the providers and spend the quarter
million on the birth centers and because
that's tiny money and and babies matter
so so that's it I'm sort of done talking
about this spreadsheet when when we come
back on Monday kind of what I'd like to
be able to do is just
hear how much money you that we want to
spend I I'm I'm saying 40 maybe I'm
actually saying 50.6 if we reach back
and grab the hospital's 3.1 share but
but that's that's how I'm sort of
targeting the amount you guys have a
different way of doing it
um and and I've just laid out for you
how I would prioritize this document we
didn't talk about Pharmacy or durable
medical equipment but I've been
encouraged to move on
so
speak speak to Pharmacy and durable
equipment if
we need to go further into that I don't
want to cut you off I just wanted to
learn no no no I haven't allocated any
money for pharmacy and durable medical
equipment in this and in order to
community ask for it so I didn't wasn't
aware of it it makes sense
those are really big dollars so go ahead
go ahead
so under our federable medical equipment
under our Managed Care Program because
there's a lot of commoditization of
durable medical equipment
we
pay we have as a floor that the mcos can
pay uh 80 percent of Medicaid fee
schedule so what's happened in the DME
space is that a lot of the providers are
getting below
what the Medicaid fee schedule is
because
some of the large contracts can can get
it for dirt cheap and what what I've
heard from the
um the DME network over time is that
they would like the minimum fee schedule
to be the minimum Medicaid fee schedule
which from a couple years ago that was
probably about a three million dollar
issue to to bring rates back to the full
Medicaid fee schedule but the the issue
with DME is like the easy stuff
um is been commoditized when you want to
try to get someone to go to the North
Country to see that one person or to to
do some of the if you will I almost
think of it like what goes on with the
mail delivery and and delivery of
packages that there's a certain
component that the the in-state
providers are sort of like the U.S mail
in the sense that they have to go to
Every household or they try to anyways
and and some of the other d me products
are just more you know you can get them
through Amazon or something like that
it's I mean I'm just using analogies
here not
direct things but that's that's what's
happening I think to the DME providers
that they're looking for that to be
where they want to get to we we did when
we did the procurement
um
they were getting paid less than 80
percent by
okay do you have any comments on
Pharmacy
I think in terms of uh Pharmacy just to
give you some sense of the scale in the
in the Health Care Program it's a it's
approaching 20 percent of the spend
um
and
um you know again here in terms of what
uh
the way I think it affects the local
pharmacies is what what what they get in
terms of dispensing fees for from the
mcos in terms of allowances there that
the the drugs are bought on a more of a
national Market I guess I want to jump
to the bottom line is the money to pay
for the extra Pharmacy costs already in
the governor's budget or do we need to
go find some additional money to pay for
the additional Pharmacy expense we're
anticipating
I've not to be give you sort of a yes or
no answer that I think yes it's in it's
in there but I I can say that you know a
large in large measure the independent
pharmacies have largely disappeared and
that the the way the the pharmaceutical
business is going is that more narrow
networks are being developed to to
accommodate the the efficiencies that
are needed to work within the current
budgets
so I guess the answer is I think that we
feel that we can acquire the pharmacies
Pharmaceuticals we need and deliver them
with the budget that we have that being
said I think if you talk to the few
remaining Independent Pharmacies they
would feel like they're they're probably
just hanging on do you have a comment
there representative stream because what
I think the summary of that is we don't
need to be looking to put more money in
the pharmacy and and that if we did
anything with the durable medical
equipment it'd be a three million dollar
bill yeah the the DME is a relatively
minor part the pharmacy we probably
don't have to address it in the budget
from what I'm hearing here uh with
additional Appropriations but I will say
the pharmacy processes are a lot more
difficult to control we heard testimony
about pending drugs that may cost two
million dollars for a single patient and
being covered under the Medicaid Program
and I'm not sure we have the checks and
balances and
um uh budget type of controls in place
to be dealing with that but that would
certainly be outside of of uh approving
hb2 and uh a responsible budget for the
next biennium
so so I think there are some processes
in place to where these really
budget-breaking kinds of new drugs get a
review and they get a clinical
Effectiveness assessment the research
has looked at and
but but even with those things in place
I'm nervous that we're going to like
blow out our budget at some point
because we need tighter control still
do you have any thoughts on that yes
um
we've been working and preparing for the
next procurement on we've got sort of
mapped out when we expect all these
different and I could share that at
another occasion with you in terms of
when all these potentially very large
you know million two million dollar dose
type of treatments are scheduled to be
on board we we fortunately
um and Medicaid can take some we're
allowed six months once it's FDA
approved to sort of work up the criteria
and we're also looking at what other
states are doing with our actuary in
terms of how we can manage those costs
uh potentially better but when I include
talked about the three percent
inflation factor that we built into our
rates that's intended
for the 24 and 25 period to cover where
we think we can live with with respect
to the budget in terms of those things
longer term I think when you go beyond
25 you know the momentum of these larger
types of of therapies Gene therapies
um you know we're going to need some
other strategies I think in the next
biennium budget Beyond this one
and we are working on them so HHS
oversight put in a bill to look at
emerging medical Technologies and come
up with policy recommendations and this
was one of the reasons we thought that
need was needed is because we've got
these budget busting things in the on
the horizon but okay so I I think we're
closed on the the the Medicaid targeted
rate reimbursement for now
so
what would you like to do next
I'm willing to just sit back and let you
you might want to have your Vice chair
do that can she read your mind do you
go ahead you you you've been a vice
chair you can do this well I would just
go back to what Mr Lipman was and let
him start I mean he you know started off
with something and I think he's got
the ability to go through the whole
thing right am I mistaken about that
I think you could go through this yes so
I handed out a uh
a house bill 2 tracking sheet of sorts
and I apologize you've already seen
several House Bill 2 summary sheets but
what I would like to do going forward as
the division meets each morning is
update this with the action taken by the
division uh so if a section has been
approved we would show that if it's on
hold we would show that if there are any
amendments or it's been deleted we would
show that
um
so I'm not sure if the division is
prepared to vote on these right now
um
but I guess what I would suggest
in the case of House Bill 2 not
necessarily in the case but of House
Bill lawn is taking an affirmative vote
taking a vote to delete anything you
would like to delete and taking a vote
to amend anything you would like to
amend and I do have a stack of potential
amendments here and anything that you're
not ready to vote on yet and you'd like
do you have an ordered stack or we just
start going through or how do you it
might it's not necessarily an order but
I can I can try to rearrange it so yeah
I think if you want to start with the
um I might see just just starting with
the first item on the list and working
so um if you want to start with sections
49 through 50 on page 20 of House Bill 2
this is 1.5 million in fiscal 23 for
juvenile peer-to-peer grief support
programming
so I'll give my opinion if you want me
to speak first I I want you to share it
for a while so this is where I'm
starting I'm not sure what document
we're looking at right now but but
that's awesome so he handed that Mr
Ripple handed out something that says at
the top house finance division three
actions related to hb2 as of March 17
and it's a big long vertical list of
about
I don't know 40 items from the from hb2
starting with 60 49 15 going down to 254
looks like this
you you have that or no I I do uh just
question is this kind of identical to
the original sheet you gave us or
something's been added and subtracted
it's very similar and that's why I
apologize for the overlap but going
forward each morning I want to update it
with the status of the division's action
so that's why I started with a new
format
does everybody have the
you
oh just didn't have it okay all right
but how about the Mary Jane yeah
okay okay Maureen
okay
so on that so on that first item
sections 49 through 50 I'm not sure if
the division is is prepared to act at
so I'll start back with my opinion I
just assumed take this out but let's go
on the room and get over his opinion
and I'll just added this was put in with
the governors I recall a not uh not
originally by from DHHS not mistaken I'm
that was my question too is is this
something that the the department has
been
funding previously
um sure so so this was not a prioritized
needs request um I do have Katya Fox
here to to speak to this item if if
you'd like additional information though
I mean I would at least like a very
short explanation of what it is bring
yes ma'am
it looks like this
that sort of gives an explanation of
what each one of these things is
yes I'm I actually have my own version
of it but yeah for everybody else if you
don't have that it might help to bring
so um the response is we have not funded
this in the past
um and
um
it was previously stated about where it
let me just ask if it was funded what
would you do with it
so we would
um initiate a procurement process and
solicit applications from eligible
providers to provide this service for
yes sir so my my thought on this is that
uh we we know that we're going to want
to spend a lot more money than what we
have and so occasionally we're going to
have to make the hard decisions on on
what not to fund and all this is not a
lot of money it's a brand new program
that's going to have some stumbling
Growing Pains anyways before it can be
effective I I I would rather take the
limited amount of money we have and
focus it as much as possible on Direct
Health Care with with proven outcomes I
anybody for a straw vote is that a fair
thing to ask at this point or is that
too much for us to get to that point
you may recall that representative
Weiler wanted to be present for any of
those kind of votes okay okay well
yeah I see
if I could just maybe
um some of these things that we
like this is a new program so maybe we
want to put like a special Mark so we
know we can go sort of go back
and go over them when we see what we
have when we get to the end
yep
[Laughter]
so so I think if the division doesn't
vote on anything the division doesn't
vote on today I'll mark As on hold for
the next time I prepare this document
okay
so
if you're not ready to vote on 49 and 50
we can move on to section 77 and 78
which make a 10 million dollar
appropriation of Das for the purpose of
constructing a replacement facility for
the sununu center and I do have an
amendment for that
that I'll hand out
can I describe it while you're handing
it out
so the idea here this is 10 million of
General funds the
uh Governor's budget or hp2 I believe
includes I don't includes that are not
but the intention is that the rest would
come from arpa funds the suggestion of
this amendment it was we delete the 10
million dollars of General funds from
here and basically put through an
amendment that says all the funds for
so go ahead sir so what happens if um
there aren't enough arpa funds to fully
fund the construction I would ask Mr
Ripple to address that but he says if we
pass it into law they'll have to
and just to let you know I I'm I'm okay
with that whole concept I all I know is
the governor promised 15 million not
21.6 and I just you know if we're going
to hold them accountable for all 21.6 I
just I'm curious what we think the odds
I'm not sure how much is currently
unexpended but as the Amendments is
written
if by the time this goes into effect the
entire amount has been allocated it
would require the department to dip into
funds that have already been allocated
this really concerns me a little bit I
uh
I still you know I still sort of wonder
I didn't feel like I ever finally got my
questions answered
about whether or not some at some point
someone's going to say Arbor funds
cannot be used
for incarceration facilities and
some people feel very comfortable with
it I still feel a little bit
uncomfortable and
I think we had it yesterday in the bill
we passed I think we did have a
statement about there was a section
about how the new facility would be
would be funded so I'm I'm really
worried about this and
um going forward that we I want to make
sure that the funds are in place so that
we can get moving on this
I 100 share your concern my impression
from the meeting yesterday was that
everybody that spoke was very clear that
the Attorney General had spoken up and
said no problem and at this point given
that we're in the house phase not the
Senate phase this gets us back 10
million dollars of General funds which
will go a long way to helping us with
our other
big problem we were discussing this
morning so that's kind of the way I'm
I I will have to say I was pretty
comfortable that we weren't going to be
excluded based on what I heard which was
the Attorney General
followed the the trail on what the
possible concern was and saw saw no
evidence in the state of Maine that
there's been any pushback on that I mean
nothing's guaranteed but I I was pretty
comfortable that we had done a
reasonable level of due diligence on
that one point anyway there may be other
issues with this amendment but
but even with that
um
I think yesterday I think we were
thinking that we were going to have arpa
pain for 15 million
agreed this would basically be shift in
that
and as I say it just puts the burden on
the Senate to figure out what to do
we we have a they have an easier problem
let's face it
they're already doing some bills that
probably going to impact their budget
but plus they're also going to see
different Revenue numbers so I this I
think helps us with some of these other
issues that we're going to be facing
here
and if we need to put on hold they'll
put it on hold but if we can get it
through would be nice and get one thing
done
I'd accept a straw vote if you took one
uh representative Wilder's not here do
I just left division two he's there sure
and just you got to jump on things while
we're waiting
so the next
two 89.90 and 99 I believe were what we
discussed earlier today so I'm hopeful
that maybe at least have the background
for that
does he have this representative Weiler
do you
thank you representative Wally
so we're looking at
number the second item which is uh
section 77 78
which is the 10 million dollars of
General funds
going toward the construction of the
sununa center and it's been suggested
that we take that out
and put in this amendment which I'm
assuming you also have does did you hand
uh it's number two 2023 1053h
which essentially says take all the
funding for the sununa center out of
arpa funds
and and we'll take it out of here for
the 10 million of General funds we'll
take out of here for the time being
which will give us 10 million of General
funds to use elsewhere and put the
burden on the Senate if there's issues
with the use of arpa funds so the reason
um
my esteemed chairman who demoted me uh
brought you in was we thought we would
take a straw vote on that one to see
where people stand
so maybe just a show of hands um who
would be in favor of removing section 77
okay and who's a and who is opposed
Okay so
how do you want it now I have to defer
to you Mr chair how do you want to
handle that you
look I I think we've done this mostly
together two years ago we're going to
find a lot of opportunities for us not
to agree this may very well be one so
the general way I think we should just
move forward is is when we have a straw
vote like that that we should anticipate
that we'll end up having it become the
division three position with the
expectation that those in opposition
might want to submit their own Amendment
so I would I would close this one out
with Mr Ripple to say we've made it a
decision on a six to three to go ahead
and delete
77 and 78 I think that's what you just
did so straw boat is going to be a vote
is that well I so here's what I think
we're what we're trying to get to and it
doesn't have to be a vote in the sense
of being final but a really good if Mr
Ripple can start putting together the
that she's that that's been coming out
from Mr Kane regarding where we stand
and be really nice if we had an idea
this is where we stand if we based on
our straw votes it doesn't I think what
Sherman was saying was we don't need to
have it locked in and we come back on
Monday and the vote changes we'll take
it back out again but I'd really like to
I like it that's fine yeah I just I just
didn't want a straw boat to be a to be a
vote and that would change the process
for me
Mr chair I believe we heard from
I go over to division two and that the
world changes um I believe the chairman
of Finance had reached out to the
attorney general and found that this was
acceptable so it makes sense that we
okay go ahead go ahead so if I could I
just so I just had one question on the
voting process is your expectation then
that you would come back and take
another vote on each of these items in
the future I okay to representative
stringham's Point these are straw votes
this this is to give you some guidance
on how to focus your time and and and
prioritize your thoughts we're going to
end up coming back on Monday and taking
all the hard votes so any of these that
we want to revisit on Monday we can
revisit them on Monday but
yes
given that we've just taken a straw vote
um is there any objection from the three
dissenting that we make this a final
vote now or if does do things change
over the next 72 hours in terms of this
are you guys willing to do the the final
vote now let's representative
stringham's objection he and he voted on
the prevailing side okay so so he he he
he is right to think that there's a
distinction between a straw vote and a
real vote and that he was just doing a
straw vote
where I was going was
um it was does any member object to
I would assume that if there were some
incredible piece of information that
came to us between now and Monday
we would go back to any of these even if
we called it a final vote
okay so we would reconsider so I'm I'm
okay if we take a real vote now and make
this our position and then if there's
new information we we then reconsider
that vote because of new information Mr
Stringham yeah I guess I guess you know
I haven't caucused with the people so
they may have objections I don't
understand that might influence me so
that would make me more more reluctant
to vote in the affirmative how about
that I haven't done that process we got
about what five minutes
um we'll do straw votes for through the
next whatever a few hours obviously you
guys have to take a break in the middle
there
um but at some point we can caucus later
in the middle of middle afternoon maybe
or something and then come back and
maybe do some hard votes on some of them
with that work for everybody
okay so continuing
um
sections 89 89 90 and 99
were what we discussed this morning uh
what Mr Bill went over with first so I
don't know if you if you were here at Jr
but I'll fill you in so my personally I
would delete those
um which is basically what the
Amendments that Mr Ripple went over with
us
um did so um thoughts on that one those
two
are there any objections to deleting
those two
okay how about another quick straw vote
I'll vote Yes anybody else
okay this is unanimous can we call that
one hard
we're going to give Mr Ripple gray hair
by the end of today
so if I'm not mistaken 151 is basically
moving something to the Department of
Safety that is sort of a non-expense I I
support that anybody um I mean keep it
in other words anybody opposed to that
151 one that you had uh given to
division two so I think they've already
handled it so I can cross right off
oh I'm sorry
all right
my bad I apologize I hadn't deleted that
from my list
okay so uh where are we at 212. Choose
Love
anybody opposed to keep supposed to keep
in that sense
it's kind of in the noise
I may be in the minority I I um it's not
a lot of money uh but I really think
that it's important for us to focus uh
scarce resources on Direct Health Care
as much as possible direct Health Care
I hate to be against love
okay wait some somebody didn't vote
[Laughter]
so it's deleted right yeah yeah yes
barring some disaster over the weekend
and
Yugoslavia or something
so I think representative erf yes sir
those positions are filled with
individuals
sorry I was waving my hand I apologize
and now they permanent temporary
semi-permanent this this particular hb2
provision this transfers those positions
in the program from the governor's
office to the Department of Health and
I think that meets the new information
does anybody want to change their vote
I I really don't I I uh is given the
enormous vacancy rates we have all over
the state I if those folks were
reapplied into higher productive more
important tasks that would be okay with
me
[Music]
where are they now I'm sorry
they they are currently in the executive
branch so they're within the governor's
office right now they work
collaboratively with the Department of
uh education department of safety and
the Department of Health and Human
Services
so that's what I was reading was that
and I would that's what I was trying to
wrap my brain around but it's not no
cost is it I see a quarter million
dollars that's the positions correct the
the no cost component is is the
curriculum I believe I believe that the
curriculum itself is free typically have
if I look at this it's actually a half a
million dollars right between the two
years
.
so would you like me to re-vote
let's have a revote who would like to
six to two Okay so I think we're in the
same
boat two opposed and
how many do we have while or no voting
okay
um
so section 213 doesn't have any money
associated with it it's the Department's
ability to fill
unfunded positions for the biennium
provided
uh
provided that the total expenditures
don't exceed the amount appropriated for
personnel
and apparently it's been in previous
Trail bills I'm not mistaken a lot of
them correct
anybody opposed to leaving that one
there
okay so I'm gonna call that in oh go
ahead sir
yes
I believe if we're going to
keep within our current Financial
constraints and we're giving everybody a
10 raise that maybe a small reduction in
the number of unfunded positions might
make sense so I'm not I'm okay with the
language of filling unbunded positions
we just might want to visit the number
that are there
if that makes sense representative i i i
i I'd like to ask Mr Ripple is this one
of the items that you identified as a
suspension that we've done multiple
times and that we were going to try to
restructure it so that we just do it
permanently
I was not under the impression
that there was a consensus yet that you
would want to do this permanently but it
is definitely an item that's been in
previous trailer bills I think at least
the last five so that was my my thought
wherever we ended up on it is that I I'd
like to just start cleaning up hb2 and
just do this permanently so that we're
not doing it in two years
okay
um you can do that I can have a house
bill two Amendment drafted I don't have
it available now but if that was if
that's the committee's intent now I
think you could take that tentative vote
and then I could have the amendment
prepared
okay let's vote
um I have a question a question go ahead
no I I asked what are we what's oh I'm
sorry um section 213 allows DHHS to fill
unfunded positions during the bayennium
provided that expenditures do not exceed
the amount appropriate for personnel
costs and as stated it's been in a
number of previous travel bills in fact
I think consecutively going back for the
last four or five at least
so the question is to keep it so well
um
there's I guess there's two questions
what chairman Edwards was proposing is
keep it permanently
or so there's sort of three choices keep
it permanently keep it for the biennium
take it out
yes sir Mr Weller representative
some years ago we had a suggestion from
then Governor Lynch any position that
was empty for 18 months wasn't needed
I think I would like to go along with
that
well I don't disagree I don't think this
directly
addresses that this is just if there are
any that are unfunded they have the
ability to move them around or is that a
correct understanding
and I guess I'm thinking a minor tweak
to the language which is any unfunded
position that has been unfunded for
right meaning temporarily vacant for the
last 12 months they could fill but not
necessarily all of those that have been
ongoing
I don't know if that's something that
I don't understand I don't understand
the distinction of uh 12 months
so at some level right this the work is
getting done already by the remaining
staff members so there is some period of
time
we can discuss whether that's 12 months
18 months 10 years but at some point we
have an unfunded position that is not
actually doing work because it hasn't
been filled for a very long time I don't
know where that threshold is that we can
debate whether it's maybe it's 24 months
but there's some period we're carrying
positions in right as as possible filled
positions that have not been filled and
the work is still being done so at some
point we should get rid of those vacant
positions and I think that's a
reasonable excuse me one second I'm
going to Chairman's privilege
to keep the process moving since we have
some disagreement here I'm just going to
say when we put that I'm going to hold
for now and we'll come back to it
because I think it's not worth arguing
over right now if that's acceptable
we have to yes I'm sorry
I'm sorry
so what time do you want to come back
sir uh what do you what do you need
an hour 45 minutes what do you need
okay I I suggest we come back at ten
after one
so call it a lunch break
is that reasonable okay
all right
and and representative Hall I would
there on this March 6 document there's a
description of what we're trying to do
with this unfunded thing you're you
don't have a bad idea it's just not what
this hb2 item's about
I understand and maybe it has to be
taken up separately I agree with I agree
with the unfunded positions right it's
more about what do we do with the
all right it being uh 10 minutes after
one uh I'm gonna call division three
and we still have a few people coming in
which is okay because it was a good
lunch I'm sure uh we we uh we finished
talking about
um section 213 on the hb2 but before we
start pile driving through hb2 again
Vice chair Mooney has a document from
the he she wants to discuss
thank you Mr chairman so I have
distributed to all of the division three
members a copy of an email dated March
14th from our attorney General John
formella to our chairman Weiler
discussing the use of arpa funds for the
Youth Detention Center build now the it
is a two-pages physical Pages three
pages one double-sided unstapled but a
critical summary is really in the first
paragraph of page one saying whether
arpa funds can be used and so forth and
a detailed explanation is below the
answer is they can be used for such a
purpose so that is at everybody's place
at this time
no no of course that doesn't uh include
any advice of the availability of the
funds just the authorization to use the
funds so so we still have um maybe an
open question that can be uh answered
later but
um go ahead
there's no question that we have not the
state has not uh spent is the wrong word
but and appropriately it's not the
probably the right word either but
there's still funds that have not been
dedicated to what is that whatever the
right word is allocated so we're the
legislature
so I don't disagree with you I I the
people who are accountable for the funds
just haven't committed to us yet that
doesn't have any bearing on whether or
not we should put it into hb2 I just
leave it as an aspect that's not yet
pinned down we pin down that the
authority is there to spend this money
on this project
with the AGS letter
yes sir Mr chair thank you um is it
possible I I think representative Weiler
or chairman Weiler forgetting this is it
possible that we can get this over to Mr
Ripple that a copy of this be made
available to the General Public
this letter
I I don't have a problem with that a lot
of this goes on the website anyways you
see any reason why we wouldn't post this
or I can put it online I don't know what
it is I don't think I've seen it
it's an email from Mr formella to
representative Weiler with a copy to a
few people I don't recognize and it
essentially clarifies the authority to
spend arpa money on this um
replacement Center which I would
describe as a
an element of our
continuity of care in uh
trauma and the trauma informed care
I have not read the full letter I agree
that the first paragraph says exactly
what representative Mooney just said and
it's probably worthwhile at least
documenting we spent three minutes on
this can we move on
thank you so
um I I now I'm going to go backwards to
item 2 213 DHHS ability to fill unfunded
positions
um I I think we we let this conversation
get a little convoluted the the hb2 item
uh is is fairly clear I think in that we
have historically as a form of
boilerplate allowed the department to
fund unfunded positions to respond to
emerging needs so that they could you
know move uh and reallocate money the
the the the issue here was
one do we want to approve this hb2 item
and if so do we want to request that it
be made more permanent rather than
something that we see every two years so
let's do two questions one at a time is
there anyone who wants to withdraw the
historical ability of the department to
move money around to fund unfunded
positions
I'm opposed to leaving it that way but I
think I'm in the minority and I have no
objection to proceeding if you guys do
does anyone else have any opposition
because I would like to take a straw
poll on that
okay so uh if you are in favor of
retaining 213 as written please raise
one two three four five
if you are opposed to leaving section
213 as is please raise your hand
one
oh okay so that's the next vote that's
the next vote right right now this vote
is do you want to keep this language or
not
or do you want to allow them
okay but you want to make it permanent
so so you I think are actually a yes
okay
so so did you vote representative
nordgren
okay so so there we are seven one now
the next vote is shall we ask Mr Ripple
to convert this language to make this
permanent Authority I'm in favor of
doing that uh are there any questions
comments okay raise your hand if you
would like to see this as a permanent
Authority
okay who's somebody's counting I hope
okay now opposed two so we have six to
two so so there you have it uh Mr Ripple
you have any questions about that I do
not okay thank you
um now we're on 214
um this establishes a program where we
reimburse senior companion and Foster
grandparents for stipends program was
suspended for the current biennium I
don't recall the history is there a
history of suspending this
there's a history of suspending it that
goes back to the 12 13 budget it was
however funded in 2021 but the
department did not expend those funds so
it's been effectively suspended for a
decade
so
um
so this is again another two-part vote
in my in my opinion one is do you want
to maintain hb2 as is as a concept and
then the next second vote will be
whether or not you want to make it
permanent so those are two distinct
decisions do you have a question there
representative Wallner I just I'm just
I'm going to
I'm going to vote to leave it the way it
is and the reason is because this is a
program that
a senator is
very dedicated to and I think maybe the
decision as to what to do with this
should come in the Senate because
there's someone there that has spent a
lot a lot of time on this program and
has over the years been a real advocate
for it
okay so I understand what you just said
to mean that you're okay with leaving
this hp2 item but that you don't care to
make it permanent
um could we see a show of hands for the
first vote is do you want to keep H this
okay I've got a question go ahead what's
your I'm confused right we have a
program we're suspending the program so
if we leave this in the budget or I
assume that's suspending the continuing
the suspension
the program continues to be suspended
okay the distinction is we've been doing
this for 10 years with one term
exception that still didn't get funded
okay I just so if I'm voting for in
favor of this I just want to make sure
right we are suspending this for one
more term this is a suspension for one
more term yes and I'm a yes okay so so
again the straw vote if you're in favor
of maintaining this hp2 line item please
raise your hand
okay I see Stringham behind me that's
unanimous eight nothing right
okay for completion then let's go ahead
and do the other one which is how many
of you would make this permanent as
opposed to two years raise your hand one
two three four
okay
okay so the next vote is how many are
you opposed to making this Tournament of
the permanent one two three represent an
organ four so it'd be in tide there is
no vote so we'll continue it as is and I
I don't care to talk about this on
Monday again unless we have to
okay so
um
congregate housing and services
suspension is item 215
Mr Ripple can you talk about that
this is another one that's been
suspended in every budget since 12 13
with the exception of 2021 and again the
department did not expend those funds in
2021.
is there any discussion on that
because you see the pattern we're going
to vote to see if you accept the hb2
line item as is
okay so straw vote
um on 215
do you want to accept this hb2 line item
okay that looks unanimous to me eight to
nothing
okay so now we're on 216 Cola increases
I think that's cost of living allowances
not soda increases for elderly and adult
clients under the social services block
grant
do you want to talk to us about this
it is it's boilerplate that the
department has had going back quite a
while there was only one budget I think
in the last decade in which it was not
included
um
and that's that's really all I have on
that I don't know if Nathan's able to
on the actual um
cost of living adjustments
the the the cost is is generally de
minimis and absorbed within our budget
so effectively this is no budgetary
impact that the fiscal committee can
even finance committee can even see
right correct okay
so is there anyone opposed to this hp2
line item
this is your time to say so
no no you don't want to discuss it
you're just in the minority okay
representative erf does not like this
um okay so uh we're going to do a straw
vote do we retain
to section 216 as written raise your
now raise your hand if you're opposed so
okay now we're on to two seven Mr chair
go ahead I'm reserving the right after I
read that section completely to vote on
it one day if we can I I I don't think
we have to say that every time uh I I
think on Monday we're going to have an
idea of what we really want to talk
about the controversial stuff but if
anyone has anything that we've already
agreed on that we want to come back and
revisit everything is open for
reconsideration on Monday just based on
any members uh discretion okay
yes are we going to be moving anything
along today
I think we are okay great you know every
everything that we're telling uh Mr
Ripple is okay he's going to be
anticipating it's okay until we come
back on Monday and change our minds
and I'm hoping we're not changing our
minds but you never know right so you'll
get a new sheet and I'll record
everything you've done today as
tentative votes and I'll operate on the
assumption that they're going to be
final unless a member wants to take them
back up a second time
is that okay
[Music]
okay
all right
so there we are 217.
delay of the perspective repeal and
reenactment of RSA 135 and change
relative to access to the states Mental
Health Services System
do you want to say something about this
Mr Ripple sure so this is a budget
savings measure that again has been in
place since around 2012 2013.
um and it would replace one statute with
another so I'll read you the relevant
provision that's in statute now
um there
before you do that just just what is the
impact if we do this what what what
difference does it make
if you leave it as is there's no
budgetary impact if you take it out
there's potentially potentially a
budgetary impact because then the
state's 10 Community Mental Health
Centers would be required to treat
everyone
um without
triaging the severity of their their
their issues
okay and then you can read the two
District differences if you care to I I
just like knowing kind of top down where
um so
the the relevant sentence in statute is
admission to the State Mental Health
Services System and access to treatments
and other services within the system
shall be contingent upon the
availability of Appropriations the
community mental health program
responsible for providing Services shall
conduct a clinical assessment of every
applicant for services
and the community mental health program
shall prioritize delivery of services
based on the severity of the
individual's clinical needs so that's
the budget saving provision right there
so if you leave section 217 as is that
language will continue for another two
years if you take Section 217 out that
language will be gone and the Community
Mental Health Centers will have to treat
everyone
okay any questions about that you've
seen this before so do you have any
Mike wasn't on but I think he said it
was important to leave it in yeah okay
is there any opposition to this section
I'm not seeing any so quick show of
hands if you're in favor
okay unanimous I think representative
nordgren
yeah
and then the next question is
do we want to do this every two years or
do we want to try to convert this to a
permanent
do you have a thought on that Mr Ripple
uh my only thought is that you might
compared to some of the other sections
that are in here you might you might
hear from some Advocates if you made
this permanent
okay so that's a great financial
analysis I just heard
thank you from the O for the LBA so
um okay so does anyone want to I'm going
to ask you a show of hands if you want
to try to convert this to being
permanent instead of every two years
raise your hands if you're in favor of
permanency
I see one
okay uh are there those that would be
are you abstaining you know I got we
have a serious I don't care but so this
you I can't hear you because I'm deaf
it
okay
oh I get it that's funny
it's it's only 1 30 and we already don't
care this is this is so good thank you
thank you so much all right a little
slow on the uptake
um
okay this is why you have a vice chair
that can still hear Jeremy needs coffee
do you have something
okay I said chairman needs coffee
so so uh 218 direct and indirect
graduate medical
education suspension I I even remember
this one so uh what do you want to say
about this uh Mr Ripple
uh this is another with my standard
comment that it's been suspended
regularly since 12 13.
and there can't be much of an advocacy
group for this by now so this could
possibly be a permanent thing so so
let's do it in two votes how many of you
would like to retain 218 as written
please raise your hand
okay representative nordgren are you is
that a hand raise or not no okay so all
those opposed raise your hand so we got
a one so that's a seven to one to keep
the language as is do you do you want to
say why representative Northern while
yeah I think there was a reason we
started doing this and it really was in
particular to encourage New Hampshire
students to be enrolled in the medical
school and this was like helping with
their tuition so
foreign
yeah so I still would be committed to
that okay
um thank you uh so we have a strong vote
to retain
um and you guys can talk about that over
the weekend but
um so next uh I'd like to see if anyone
wants to make it permanent I I would
like to do as much to clean up hb2 as
possible so I'm going to vote Yes to
make it permanent
show hands if you want to make it
permanent one two three four uh those
opposed to making it permanent
I assume you're opposed okay so that
that does not carry so we're going to do
this on a
um
item 219
catastrophic Aid to hospitals suspension
Miss Ripple again suspended regularly
since the 1213 biennium
so just comment on on on what this does
um uh because it is related to other
things that we've been talking about and
catastrophic Aid let's say somebody gets
stuck in the hospital for 150 days and
they get a 200 000 payment and the
Medicaid drg payment is eight thousand
dollars at some point
um catastrophic claims support kicks
into the hospital
um you know doesn't end up paying for
for that that patient 100 on their own
there's a kick in from the state and
obviously they haven't been doing that
and the hospital
Association uh did say that uh that that
it had been taken out of the budget many
times and they didn't specifically ask
it to be put back in but
um I think it is
um
uh you know a good idea to
um keep it in in the long run and not
make it a permanent cut so even if we
take it take out catastrophic payments
okay so that sets up uh two votes uh on
219 first to keep the language as is for
the biennium uh those in favor raise
representative norgren okay that's
unanimous those that would make it
permanent raise your hand
okay four
those that would oppose making it
permanent raise your hand
represent an organ okay so the that does
okay so we're on
220. do you want to talk to us about 220
sure
so section 220 states that in the event
that Appropriations in the Medicaid to
schools accounting unit are insufficient
the department may come to fiscal to
accept and expend additional federal
funds and that any such requests include
a detailed explanation of the types of
assistance the department is providing
to local school districts to help them
ensure eligibility for reimbursement so
this was an issue two years ago I
believe there were some stories in the
news in which school districts were
providing services but were not
receiving reimbursement and so this
section was added to house bill 2. so it
was first in-house Bill to
Mr Roy do you have any comments about
the current perception of the potential
demand for this
so I I think this is an area that that
as Kevin pointed out it has been uh
difficult to predict because it is based
on whether a school chooses to
participate in the program we've
budgeted approximately 17 million
dollars each year in 2022 the actual was
14.38
um as this shows up in the in the state
budget this this shows up as a hundred
percent federal funds so this would be
the additional acceptance of federal
dollars
okay to summarize the things I just
heard is there's no State money this is
all federal if we keep the language as
is correct all right not not to be a
mercenary but uh all right so are there
any conversations or discussions about
this anyone opposed to maintaining this
language
uh seeing then let's do a straw vote if
you're in favor of maintaining this
language raise your hand
okay that's unanimous
um is this subject a subject for a good
subject for making it permanent it
doesn't feel like it if it's it's only
been around once
um I have no thoughts but as you
mentioned it isn't it isn't long-term
boilerplate like the other sections
you've been discussing
all right so so for I I think I'm okay
with just leaving it for the biennium is
there any opposition to just leaving it
for the biennium
leave it okay eight nothing
all right so now we're on 221
so this would allow
the department to carry forward funds
from the division of Medicaid services
and I believe Nathan mentioned this is
projected to be about five million
dollars this year uh into the next
biennium and treat it as restricted
revenue for the purpose of funding
Medicaid
okay we have talked about this in
previous hearings I don't recall anyone
really being opposed to this is anyone
opposed to it now uh representative let
me ask you a question
so this is what you just said Kevin that
basically this year it would lapse five
million dollars that this was removed
that's correct yes which essentially
gave us another five million dollars in
Surplus to work with
it would okay so yeah I'm opposed just
because we need money
um for all these other things we're
doing so that's my reason for being
opposed also if we but just to do the
other side of that coin if if we do roll
it Forward isn't this a source of funds
for what we may want to do next fiscal
year for
paying for some of these targeted rate
increases and the like if if we if we
lapse it it goes to the rainy day fund I
believe and it's harder to get back down
out of the cloud to fund anything we
prove that this this would otherwise be
a 23 laps and any excess that you have
in 23 would go into the rainy day fund
and be harder to access in later years
but what could we access it right now so
to speak you could access it if you were
to make a an appropriation out of fiscal
so I I just want to follow up on that
are you are you thinking you want to
change this language so that any lapse
goes to something directed that you may
have an idea for well yeah I gotta
where's that page
yeah so I got I got 100 million if
you're talking to this side of the
defense except for my good friend over
here and 200 million talking to the
other side of the fence from what I hear
so five million would help
that's all I'm thinking that instead of
just having it rolled into where
Medicaid can use it and I get that it's
useful to them as well but if we're
trying to punch a lot of money into a
specific areas
it's another five million dollars okay
so I'm hearing you would not accept this
language as is you would want to amend
this hp2 item so that we can direct the
5 million to something more targeted
yes tremendous as needed if if that's
what's required do you have a comment
representative hole that was good I was
going to ask the same thing and Mr
Ripple draft something up we just need
to figure out where we would like to
push the money to
do you have comments I just want to be
sure I'm clear that this this would
become 23 money
is that right we would have to spend it
in 23. so the the the purpose of this
particular section was to bring forward
funds from this current biennium into
the next for this program because we are
dealing with what is an unprecedented
situation where our Medicaid roles have
increased up to 250
000 and we do a plan to and we and we do
intend to disenroll
um tens of thousands of individuals we
have a lot of assumptions we have very
good predictive models but at the end of
the day those are predictive models it's
a plan it's a Point of Departure this
allows a little bit of wiggle room to
address that if we are wrong then we may
[Music]
Italy
Mr Ripple has a comment it depends on
how you choose to use it if you delete
this section that's exactly right you'll
have five million dollars in fiscal 23
to spend out of 23 money you could
revise this section to carry it forward
and spend on some other purpose in 24
25.
the more straightforward approach would
representative hole I apologize for
missing the discussion this morning but
it might be relevant now that if we
pushed this amount of money over to some
of the proposed rate increases that
we're talking about
um that was like 40 million dollars if I
recall from earlier our earlier
discussions
that would help offset some of the costs
that we need to come up in this biennium
and I don't know if Mr Ripple can make
language that says it but that would be
one place I would be proposing to push
the money I I have a question is go
ahead before you do though just because
you missed the discussion the uh our our
friends on the other side of the aisle
are thinking in terms of 200 million
while we're thinking in terms of 50
million so so this 5 million is is you
know budget dust in the balance between
those go ahead represent stream yeah so
if if we if we just kept this that money
would be in Medicaid and it could be
used for rate increases
uh as written is that correct
which is what we were talking about
earlier today
yes again again the the lapse figure is
projected um we're still a number of
months out so the five million dollar
figure is is a certain assumption
I want an absolute guarantee going
all right so
so I you know every time I've heard this
I felt like this is sort of a shock
absorber so that as we're we're getting
people Unwound from the current
eligibility if we make any errors you
know there's some money in there to to
give us a cushion to continue uh with
with funding without the department
having to come to the fiscal committee
and that by the time we get completely
through with the unwind in a in a year
or so
it just has felt to me that the odds of
this there being much of that five
million are fairly low so every time
I've heard this I've been led to leave
it thinking that we should leave this
paragraph alone but I'm open to
Representatives thoughts I well I don't
disagree with your comments I would note
that there's another item in hp2
specifically dedicated to the issue you
just raised which is the whole rolling
off thing it's not coming from this
piece
I mean not to say it can't come from
this piece but there's a whole piece
dedicated to that I'm curious do you
it's uh on page 80 uh section 237 it's
it's a 16.38 or 16.35 8 million dollars
um I I think one important thing to
remember
um that that particular figure that is
based on our best estimate at this point
in time
um when we when I'm thinking about the
carry forward and you can probably very
clearly Mark see my perspective on it
um that is a it's almost surrounding
error when we look at the total budget
for Medicaid it's it's relatively small
amount so our estimates on a on a
regular basis are are very very good
they're generally within a percentage
point it's just that every single person
that is unenrolled or disenrolled from
the program has a right to an appeal and
while they are in that appeal status we
have to keep paying uh for for for them
uh so that's that's just a risk that I
okay so so so being and personally
agnostic about the policy issue then the
that secondary issue for me is keep it
simple
uh it by not changing it it's less work
for Mr Ripple and OLS and it's it's
still a safety net uh and there's no
downside what's the downside if we put
the 5 million in there it's likely to be
spent somewhere on Medicaid somewhere I
would think
what's kind of the worst case it lapses
and we get to talk about it again in two
years what what's the worst case
scenario of unspent money
um best case scenario I I think from a
budget Statewide budget perspective is
it's not spent
um one case scenario I don't really want
to describe it is it's spent because
more people appeal than we originally
anticipated and we have higher costs
well okay that's the planning thing
that's what I'm planning on but if that
plan doesn't happen then we still just
have the 5 million and it's going to
lapse in two years that's what I'm
calling the worst case scenario that the
plan doesn't work we end up with the
extra money yes okay all right and so we
so if we don't spend it now in a
different way we can revisit it in two
based on that I I I'm going to vote to
leave it as is but uh I'm I'm going to
do a straw vote now uh is there any more
discussion on that lineup
okay if you are in favor of retaining
this language as is please raise your
hand
okay if you were opposed to
okay so I'm going to put that as six to
two and and and if you all want to for
Monday propose alternative language to
it what you would do with that you know
we can talk about that Monday I suppose
okay
um
section 222 do you I can't help but
think of that old TV show but 222. do
you have um
something to say about this
this requires the department to if
needed submit a Medicaid State Plan
amendment to establish and provide
preventative health care benefits under
the Medicaid Program and this is a new
section
am I right this is just a program
authorization with no specific funding
that sounds wrong
that's true there's no
so this is pure policy no money Mr chair
let me let me just finish
please that's that's well there's
clearly no appropriation whether there's
no fiscal impact I'm not sure I would
let Nathan speak to that okay but this
is predominantly policy
yes do you do you want to talk about a
fiscal impact or do you have a question
now to represent a hole I was going to
ask Mr White to fill us in on what
potentially happens if this is removed I
think we're asking the same question
okay good so so so the the this
particular item would allow us to engage
in these these cost saving programs
um through the Medicaid Program
um there are a number of citations
included in the original document that
that I I provided uh to Kevin that Who
provided to the committee that
identified a few of the examples there
um the purpose of this is to lower the
cost of the Medicaid Program in in the
long run
um and and this this would be a starting
point
I I have commentary does anyone want to
speak to this at this point
I
you know being an old HHS Alum I I would
I would like to uh
with those that perspective I'd like to
kill this and see this in a bill to be
discussed in January if not sooner I I
don't I don't know that we should be
taking on a pure policy issue uh do you
have comments
from what Nathan just said it doesn't
feel like pure policy to me it seems
like it's really here to help
save costs
particularly out into the future and
I'd say since the program doesn't exist
that's Theory it's so there's a policy
implication first do we is do we think
this is good policy or not we're
bypassing the policy committee we're not
getting their input and advice
this document that we're looking at yeah
and it it shows all the different
programs yes ma'am and I think what
representative Waldner said I mean I
think these are all preventive
programs to try to cut the budget rather
than
have us
delivering these Services when we could
be doing something to alleviate some of
them thank you so I'm just curious am I
am I the only one that's thinking that
we should just kill this out of hb2
because this is this is really first and
foremost a policy issue given that
there's no direct appropriation involved
if there's anyone does anyone else agree
with that well I I think I think you
have a point it is it is policy I mean
there is a pretty extensive effort
nationally called the national
preventative health care task force that
um that uh meets and comes up with items
like these that are essentially
self-funded medical services and
um uh I'm assuming that's where where
these come out but the word assume is a
dangerous word so
um
and um uh you know I I wouldn't mind
having Health and Human Services input
on this or oh
um uh either because these things these
things do cost money and they do save
money on the on the back the back end I
can't tell you that whether their
revenue will cost neutral or not
so
you know there's a lot of discretion
already in DHHS if if these were good
programs aren't there sister programs or
compatible programs already that could
be leveraged like I know under the
nicotine secession we do have a
department that manages in part a
smoking secession component so so so if
we don't do this in hb2
the department could still do it if they
expand these programs if they wanted to
without legislative Authority could they
not this would be explicit authorization
for the Department to submit a state
plan Amendment for these types of
programs
Mr chair uh go ahead I believe under
house Rule 36 B
right a committee the majority of the
committee can request the drafting of a
bill past the deadline if I understand
this correctly so we could pull this out
and make this its own independent bill
in parallel although I don't know that
it would complete the process for other
house deadlines until next year
but we could do what you suggested
so so we're waiting on representative
Weiler uh to to actually vote on this uh
so but I don't mind continuing the
discussion I I just would like to see
this go to a policy committee somehow
whether we you know kicked it over to
HHS now they can't complete their work
before we're done with our work but we
could maybe recommend it to a Senate
bill that perhaps they have that they
could amend i i as a rule I've been
informed by my seniors that we shouldn't
do peer policy stuff and this feels like
peer policy so
um so we're I'm gonna I'm gonna hold off
on a straw vote on this
okay so you have a bunch of stuff on
this
well what I have for you is the
Department's proposed House Bill one
budget for this Nunu Center which if the
Committees were so inclined could come
out of House Bill 2 and be funded in the
operating budget instead so would you
like me to hand that out I I think so I
I I we we have Decades of experience of
house bill one funding the sununu center
we're going to anticipate in the future
the sununu center having expenses in the
future so rather than this being the one
weird year where the budget is in hb2
this is an attempt to say do we want to
put this into hb1
I I think we do uh the question I think
that the committee should address as we
vote is is it worth the effort that
we're going to ask LBA to do to Move It
from uh because we're not we're not
debating the dollar amount right now
we're just talking about where should it
be should it continue to live in hb2 or
should we try to put it back into hb1
and and and so I'm I'm I'm open to some
discussion on that representative
Wallner
legislators are going to be sitting here
looking at the budget and they won't
have the historical numbers and I really
think that's you know it should be there
and not just blank pages
so I know why it happened this time but
doesn't I don't think it should happen
in the future I just have a technical
question for um once we do get a new
facility
um it's I presume not going to be called
the sununu Youth Services Center so will
that line item continue through or are
we going to start fresh with a new one
like where is that break going to be in
terms of bookkeeping I guess
my go ahead my guess is the line items
the history will change that there's
stay constant rather consistent it's
just the naming change at the at the top
of the line yeah we we would likely work
with the Department of administrative
services to carry that history forward
it'll probably end up being a new
accounting unit it's it's kind of a
question that we would just have to work
out with with Das to to figure out what
that would look like in in future uh
future biennia okay but just to be clear
I think I agree with representative
walner that having zeros there for the
biennium is not the best
choice for it all right
all right
um
any other discussion on this I I there
okay so there there could be a lot of
discussion on this the first part of the
discussion I want to just limit purely
to should we be putting the hb2 detail
into hb1 there's still the question
about whether or not we like these
numbers that's not the thing I'm asking
right now right now I'm just asking
where should this live hp2 or hb1 go
ahead represent or so just to clarify Mr
Ripple so we do this that essentially
gives us 21 million to play with still
with the uh FYI 23 Surplus
this is actually are we are you using
the money from the Surplus and taking it
over there this wouldn't save you any
money because you'd be removing the
appropriation in House Bill 2 and
putting it in house bill one instead
you're not putting into Hospital alone
okay
so this kind of aggravates a problem
wait let me just clarify that
so are you moving the FY 23 surplus
funds to no in in House Bill 2 it's
funded in 2425 and it would continue to
okay so two votes first vote is a simple
one keep it or move it to hb1 or not yes
means we move it to hb1 Second vote is
going to be related to a simple
discussion of whether or not these
numbers feel right to you okay so uh
stravo show of hands should we move from
hp2 to hb1 the accounting for the Sunil
Youth Center please raise your hands if
you say yes
that's unanimous okay thank you uh so so
now to the second question and this is
probably a Monday discussion because I
don't believe any of us have looked at
these numbers to where we've can tell
from a history whether this feels right
so I would like to postpone a discussion
on the details of what's in this budget
so that we can keep moving through hb2 I
would like to add just a nugget here
though
we have I think and Mr ribson is here so
he can correct me
I think we have no clue yet really what
the operating budget for the future
Youth Center is going to look like
because we don't know the design we
don't know the extent of the sharing
potential uh we you know we don't know
what we're going to have to pay to keep
the the surrounding towns whole there's
just a tremendous that we amount that we
don't know so so when we talk about what
the future operating costs of the sununu
excuse me it's a habit the future
replacement we actually don't have an
idea yet what that future operating
expense is going to be true or false
that's correct I also don't think it's
likely that it's going to be operational
in the biennium right given given the
construction time frames and everything
else so right so should we think maybe a
portion of it might be in the next
biennium we don't know
so that would be very stupid so let me
ask you a question that I think of every
time I hear a number
floated
what is going to be the process for for
the Department to go back to the
legislature to say based on these shared
services agreements you know based on
all the co-location we can do here's
what we think we can do in a wise way to
to spend these monies and and get some
sort of legislative agreement
to that kind of level of operating costs
what what does that process look like
I think it kind of depends on timing of
the development of the new facility if
it looks likely that this will be ready
you know within the next biennium I
think it would be part of the
conversation in the next budget because
at that point you'll know where it's
going we'll have plans as to what's
going to be there you know it it'll just
be much clearer even though it won't be
operational yet so I would anticipate
that if this is moving on a path that it
would be open you know a reasonable time
in the next biennium that during the
next biennium budget would be a good
time to to visit that is it also true
that based on what we passed out of the
this committee yesterday that there is a
reporting obligation to keep oversight
up to date on what you're thinking and
what's going on is that is that okay so
so there is an opportunity for us to
progressively elaborate on what the
budget might look like before Finance
ever looks at it yeah that's true okay
uh question
director ribson is it possible for
Monday before we discuss this that we
could understand Staffing levels per
shift right
not necessarily names but one nurse two
Cooks whatever counselors right whatever
type staff Broken Out by their primary
discipline and each each shift
yeah I can try
um one thing that and and you know one
thing that I would caution about is for
the YC's in particular youth counselors
in particular
um there's often folks who are on leave
there's things that you have to build in
Beyond just Bare Bones Staffing you know
in order to to account for the fact that
you unfortunately often have folks who
are on medical leave and things like
that because of things that happen
within the facility how about broadly in
terms of what the plan is in the in the
current Staffing right I think there's
87 full-time positions allocated
um one of these are full-time one of
these are contracted positions and kind
of what is their primary is it the
facilities manager is it right is it the
control room some high high level two
word three-word description of their job
and which shifts are working and I
understand when you're running a 24 7
facility you got to plan for nurse
okay okay
um one one other could you I I okay if
this is important we can do it I I'm
just concerned representative Weiler is
going to think that this is torture
cruel and unusual punishment because we
brought him back to vote on a different
issue then you're sort of done with
sununu I believe so do you think it
needs to be asked right now I was just
going to say if he's gonna if he's gonna
come back with any detail could you also
bring detail the only other big ticket
item other than employees is the medical
expenses of over a million a year so any
any color you can add to that would be I
mean I could answer that right now if
you want but I can talk about it Monday
if you want so I'm gonna I'm gonna
suspend the discussion on sununu and I'm
going to roll back to
[Music]
222 okay so we're in Room 222 Medicaid
State Plan amendment to establish and
provide preventive health care benefits
under the State Medicaid Program we had
a discussion on this
um
representative Weiler
this is basically a new program that
doesn't include any funding for now
but it permits the department to start
to further develop because in some
instances the the base of the program
may already exist but to further
development a preventive care program
that's intended to save long-term costs
and and so
um
my position on this sir was that this
since there there's no direct
appropriation of money in this hb2 item
and that some of these programs exist in
some bare minimal form at least such as
the nicotine secession program
I just assume have this go to a policy
committee as part of a statute for
debate without Finance taking the first
bite at the Apple so so my
position on this would be that we remove
section 222 and we stopped before taking
a stravo to see if he'd want to vote
boat to remove well I haven't posed a
question yet so so do you feel
comfortable of voting with us or voting
on this issue rather I do okay
all right so
um so I think the the straw vote and for
and again what we've done sir is anybody
can bring back anything on Monday if we
want to come back and revisit it we're
just trying to make some progress so
that Mr Ripple has his uh boundaries
cleared
so the strong vote is do we vote to
remove item 222 raising your hand yes is
a remote to remove 222.
raise your hand if you support removing
okay there's four if you oppose removing
222 raise your hand
okay so it re it remains all right
at this point we may have another vote
for you if you want to do another sununu
vote
uh
so so that fails That Remains
here I was all tied up in oplc oh I'm
sorry that would be so much better
okay that's most of hb2 didn't didn't we
already vote on the first part of this
we were already moving this to hp1 we
already agreed on that we're deferring
um Mr chair go ahead just one other
question for
um director ripson if he's coming back
Monday I assume he is would you please
also bring information in addition to
section 101 or class 101 I believe which
is the Medicaid payments class 18 which
is the overtime there's a million
dollars in the biennium plan for
overtime
okay
so we are on 224 DHS transfer Authority
compliance with Federal standards
Mr Ripple uh I have nothing to add other
than this is a new section that hasn't
so Mr representative Weiler and
representative Wallner with your
experience on the fiscal committee this
this feels to me like the effect of it
is to bring fewer items to the fiscal
committee committee to by granting more
flexibility is is that a is that a fair
statement Mr White will it will it have
that effect
this this would have that effect this is
to address the sub-recipient contractor
determinations that we've talked about a
few times where when we receive federal
funds under two CFR 200 331 we have to
determine whether the funds will be used
as a contractor as defined by federal
regs or a sub-recipient and sometimes
when we bring those requests forward to
transfer between those it's because
we've determined well originally we
thought it was going to be this type of
agreement now it's going to be this type
of agreement where the a contractor may
be providing services on behalf of the
department instead of to the department
and so those are the types of requests
um that that this particular provision
would address
so in summary that sounds like it's just
an execution detail deep into the
process where it turns out to be one
form of contract versus another we're
not changing the intent of what we're
trying to contract for or the dollar
amount it's just granting some
flexibility late into the process of
Contracting it it the reason that we
have that we that we want to transfer
from 74 or 102 when we're doing this is
because we want to make sure on the
federal reporting side that things are
accurate because when we get audited
they look at our sub-recipients and if
things are classified in incorrectly we
can have an audit finding resulting from
that so so what value does going through
the fiscal committee for that add what
what is the value add of going back to
the fiscal committee
um
I'll save you uh okay representative
walner or representative Weiler doesn't
feel to me like we add much value with
the fiscal committee at that point
so that makes me think we should we can
I agree
I'm fine okay all right so
um is anyone opposed to retaining
um what section am I on two two four
not seeing any opposition raise your
uh raise your hand well no it's a
unanimous thank you
225.
225 which moves from HHS to safety the
responsibility to conduct preliminary
inspection and approval for facilities
okay so there's basically two issues in
this that are sort of policy related one
is which is the correct agency in the
state to do facility licensing
and then the other is just the financial
transfer to support that policy decision
right is that fair
Mr Ripple so is I think it is okay so
so this is the department trying to give
up Health Care Facility licensing to the
yes
all right so
typically Empire Building goes the other
way so I'm prone to think that this is
okay
any anyone
opposed I have a note that this is
related to section 151 which reads about
the same and I had that crossed out
go ahead Miss Ripley well 151 was the
section that division three gave to
division two and I believe they've
already addressed and I'm not sure these
two sections actually are related
foreign
talks about who makes the inspection the
other talks about there will be an
annual inspection
and I and I'll be honest I don't
understand I don't know why 151 differs
but I've I've been told by everyone that
it does so maybe Nathan can speak about
that a little more detail sure so just
to give it a little bit of History here
so the department of safety and the
Department of Health and Human Services
had a number of conversations this past
fall and summer
um HHS has had a hard time filling uh
two positions that are associated with
this in the agency budget submission we
abolish those two positions we we
decrease our general fund amount by
approximately 238 thousand
safety increased their general fund
amount by that equivalent amount created
those two positions and the reason why
is because this actually the the
functions actually fall much more within
their day-to-day purview and we have
been unable to hire positions to do this
for I think well over a year we've had
to go out to contract and pay a
significantly higher amount than it
would actually cost for these positions
to do this work
um and so that's just a little bit of
the back story behind this particular
provision here the provision that that
was referenced earlier I'm not quite
sure where that came from and I did
speak with the Department of Safety and
they they didn't know why that was there
either and I believe division two has
okay I'm not seeing any other comments
uh I'd like to have us do a straw vote
on retaining two two five
do you have something you want to say
representable
I do I just read this and it has to do
with life safety Fire Marshal safety
right type codes which are typically not
done
by people other than the fire department
so I could understand why moving this
makes sense
all right so raise your hand if you
believe that we should retain 225 and
hb2 as written
that's unanimous thank you
um oh do you have you have an amendment
on this yes
okay let's hang on to that don't don't
let me end the day without coming back
to that
um but uh but I I'm sort of enjoying the
feeling of progress Mr chair yes well I
hate to disrupt your feeling of uh
whatever it is you're feeling you're the
one that wanted me to go faster I know
but I have to leave I have a hard stop
at about 425 so I'd rather not leave
this until the end of the day because
you and I have a difference of opinion
on this one
so I'll wait for you to leave thanks for
letting me know
fair enough
uh all right let's go ahead and break
okay you might want to put both of them
so let's let's discuss uh representative
uh Amendment first it'll be nice to see
it
you don't even need to see it
representative says just simply strike
if you'd like
background as to why I'd be happy to
provide that
I'd like to hear it
so this is essentially taking out a law
that we passed last year after a a lot
of discussion
and
apparently there's concerned on the
parts of the state that there's some
costs associated with this I don't
believe that's the case
uh and I think if we just take this out
they can deal with it and if they don't
want to deal with it they don't have to
deal with it it's a completely voluntary
program on everybody's part uh the the
uh the nurses and the hospitals wanted
the cover of the state
um as I recall and the nurses so the
program is basically concerned with
violence against particularly nurses but
in general in the medical system and
generally speaking we're talking about
clients or patients whacking their nurse
or something of that nature so the
nurses would like to see this data
collected so I presume so they can make
a case say Hey listen you guys the
hospital have to do something about this
you know where your employees are
getting hurt and you know we on the one
hand we don't want to call out the
patients because we understand that you
know they're in distress as well but we
need to deal with the problem of the
violence and the best way to deal with
it is to first of all get the stats so
that they can be collated so that's all
in the bill and representative Edwards
worked really hard on that bill
um that's the current one and I think
that just taking this provision out and
the state will figure it out thanks okay
so where do we agree we agree that this
is an important program that's being
advocated for by the hospitals and by
the health care providers that work
within the
system and
um
rather than
so we agree we agree that this program
should get started we should that's
where we're in complete agreement the
the I think a distinction is that I
actually believe the department when
they say they don't have the manpower to
meet their obligations under current
statute and the department came to us
with this hb2 asking for a suspension
and their obligations under the law
so rather than do the suspension exactly
like the department has asked us to
because I believe them
I
also want to pay attention to the
constituent groups that say that this
program is important to them
so in order to have these two realities
exist with one another my bill
suspends or is meant to suspend the
obligations of the state employees to
participate in the program while keeping
the program in place so that the private
sector can take the law as written and
go ahead and do all the things that they
need to do in order to set up kind of
this Statewide
workplace violence Commission in that
commission they basically ask that
everybody in a hospital and everyone in
sort of the three major clinics sit on
this on this commission it also brings
in the like the commissioner of DHHS or
her designee the AG or designee the
labor department or designee
and uh so there so there's active
participation by state employees on the
commission that my bill would suspend
unless they can voluntarily support it
it would also suspend a simple
obligation to establish a website that
takes some very minimalistic data from
the commission and to have it published
it also suspends their obligation to
work on the privacy and confidentiality
the privileged Communications
protections that we give this commission
it it it suspends the Department's
obligation to work that through gel car
so the Department's position as I
understand it has been very strong that
there are Manpower obligations here that
they just don't have time for at this
point and I believe them so so rather
than doing what the department said and
so just suspend the program I said no
let's find Middle Ground let's let's
suspend the obligations of the state
although you can still voluntarily do
what you are able to do but fully leave
the law in place so that the private
sector can get their own act together
I've always thought that the private
sector doesn't need to State anyways I
think they can make a tremendous amount
of progress without the state but but
for some reason they have really been
insistent on having you know kind of the
training wheels of the state attached to
this vehicle that they're trying to to
build go ahead represent the Earth
thank you Mr chair so a couple things on
line
11 the website if I'm not mistaken it
was the chairman who asked that that be
put into the law they have no problem
with that being limited nor do I but I
do understand this is my understanding I
should say that what's on line 10 the
jellicotta stuff that that is
particularly important to them and I've
like the the chairman when we had this
whole discussion several years ago last
year
um it did seem like the whole thing
could be voluntary
to me and to the chairman but it was
pretty clear that the people on the
other side didn't feel that way which is
why we went ahead and put this forward
um I didn't the AG doesn't have to show
up and people don't have to show up
there's no like there's no penalty for
any of these people not showing up at a
meeting they're all voluntary the only
thing that they really need the as I
understand especially from the nurses
the only thing they really care about is
the jail car part which protects the
confidentiality also as I understand it
that they don't feel they can do that
without the state but to ditch the
website that's fine as I say the folks
showing up that's all voluntary anyway I
don't really believe they have any
serious
and as far as keeping track of the
databases that can be on the nurses and
the hospitals as well there's no
requirement that the state take it take
they take responsibility for that
so the reason there are no penalties for
not participating is because I
explicitly removed them
so they wanted to be able to penalize
non-participation and that's that's gone
uh and and so uh so you and I are
getting to the same place in two
different ways when we're talking about
participation what what what mine says
instead of you deleting it and leaving
the statute in effects directing the AG
to a point uh a member mine simply
suspends it and says if you can do it
voluntarily go ahead in my discussions
with the nursing association explaining
to them what I'd be willing to do there
wasn't violent pushback I quit talking
to the hospital Association when I had
my Integrity attacked so I don't know if
she's continued to attack talk to you
but uh I I I have always taken the
position on this that this is a great
private sector initiative and their
obsession with having the state involved
is more than it needs to be to your
point about the gel car that is a
particularly time consuming thing for
which I think the commissioner said they
don't have the bandwidth to do that
and the privileged communication the
privacy of that we can do that in law
they don't need to do that in jail car
so there's still a way to make sure that
the confidentiality is protected but you
know what what these guys need to do
first is they need to get together and
figure out what their procedures are
because we don't know exactly what needs
to be protected and privileged until
they can come back to us and say this is
how we would actually run the the
management of the Phi so
um so I I think our amendments try to
get to the same point but but mine
basically gives the discretion to get
involved in the part of the state and
yours leaves the compulsory part of the
law in place to where we must
participate and and that's where I think
I see the disagreement between the two
approaches
foreign
any other questions comments
Mr White do you want to talk about the
position of the department on on whether
or not uh you you guys really think you
need 226.
I I I I don't think I
um the department isn't opposed to any
of this from a policy perspective I
think it really comes down to resources
um scp-459 from the 2022 legislative
session it it's it's about six pages
long and there are a number of
requirements in there for the Department
to collect analyze data conduct
follow-ups anybody that's ever been
through the administrative rules process
which is required under that it can be
it can be a six to ten month process
that's pretty in-depth
um and and there's a few other
requirements there and so
um we we just want to make sure that the
department has the resources available
to do this because we we don't have idle
idle individuals standing around to to
do this type of work today so so my
Amendment would be to be clear doesn't
say you can't do the gel car procedures
you can't do I'm not prohibiting
anything this is kind of enabling
legislation to the extent that you have
Manpower capacity to invest in this you
certainly able to because the law
remains in effect
so
um
so we have we have two amendments here
uh I I guess I guess I'll do them in
order uh if you are in favor of
Representative erf's Amendment which
deletes 226 and has the effect of
leaving in effect the current statute on
workplace violence please raise your
hand
representative Morgan do you have a vote
there no
okay so what what was that count I
didn't count it one two
three four
so don't vote if you're not sure don't
vote
this is a stravo you can vote Monday if
okay
that's that's perfectly good that's it's
better to to do that so
um so if those who are opposed to the
Okay so
so the strong the straw vote says to to
to not accept the Earth Amendment
so the next stravo is whether or not you
accept the Edwards Amendment which
leaves the law in place but provides
flexibility as Manpower is available to
participate in the program as it becomes
possible that's what this amendment does
all those in favor of the amendment
did you raise your hand Representative
walner no and with nordgren so that's
five who who's opposed one
two
I would prefer to abstain before a vote
to get to caucus with my ranking members
to hear more so so at this point I think
we're going forward with the Edwards hb2
item
but I suspect somebody will want to
um
is there anything else you'd like us to
do representative before you leave for
I know but but we're we're moving at
about four an hour so I just wanna
okay
so the next section's 227 and 228
I extend through the biennium the
Department's ability to transfer between
personal personnel class lines with
prior approval of the fiscal committee
uh this has appeared in four out of the
any any questions
if there are no questions this is just
more Department flexibility we've agreed
to in the past so do we want to retain
if if no raise your hand
okay so so we're going to keep that the
next question is is this a topic that we
might want to make permanent rather than
bringing it Forward every two years do
you have a point of view on that Mr
Ripple is this a good candidate for to
make permanent I have no point of view
on that none okay so I I want less is
more less hp2 the better so so I I would
like a straw vote on whether or not you
we want to make this permanent I will
raise raise go ahead understanding is
this is not true for some of the other
departments
what it was be more specific what is not
true for the other departments the
department of safety for instance right
does not does not necessarily have the
authority to move between classes
well being a member of division three I
think we're special
uh
but no you raised a good question is is
you know Mr chair do you have any issues
here that this that we're basically
working on a Personnel policy that's
unique to DHHS and not the whole state
we've Mr Ripple has told us we've
approved this several times in past
budgets so
so I can give you more information on
that it was not approved in 2013 and it
was not approved in 2017. you might
with those your budgets
I guess I better be consistent then
thank you
the only reason I would leave it I yeah
because I always agree with
you right
can I poke you on that every time not
not always not always
okay no the only I think it is not a bad
idea to have
it in here because it reminds us when
we're doing the budget that
that
is that's something that we're allowing
them to do and
if it's not here I don't know where it
will be I mean I don't know how we how
I I I'm not going to argue with you
because you've been doing this for 10
years uh at least so I I would just say
of the other 47 things that the Das can
do in a Personnel area that we don't
keep track of mentally all the time this
is just fall into the back Waters of
what flexibility they have from a
Personnel perspective
so I I I don't much care other than my
obsession is Let's do let's do more by
doing less if we can make this permanent
without breaking anything let's just go
ahead and make it permanent it's my
point of view did but did we we haven't
yet voted on just keeping the it as is
we did what did we do
six two seven six two six two okay yes
so so I did what I crushed you
for everyone out there
that's now one to five this week
um okay so now we're going to talk about
whether or not we make this permanent
if you want to make this permanent raise
okay if you want to not make it
permanent raise your hand okay so it's
okay so two two nine
establishment of certain unclassified
positions in abolition of certain
classified positions what are we doing
here
I would let Nathan comment on that one
sure so this section 229 this converts
to positions um two pharmaceutical
positions that we have in the division
of Medicaid services from classified to
unclassified the reason that we're
making this request these positions have
had enhancements I believe for close to
a decade so salary enhancement that have
been approved by GNC the division of
personnel recommended that we convert
these positions to better align
um just just get given the nature of the
work and given the fact that we've had
to continue doing enhancements first so
so this this dovetails actually with one
of Representative Hull's observation so
we have opportunities to move people
from classified to unclassified
positions so this is just two but these
this is a good example of two that could
be unclassified I'm I'm in support of
this HP item is there any opposition to
it
let's let's do a show of hands if you're
in favor of leaving this raise your hand
okay that looks unanimous
zero likewise establishes unclassified
positions and abolishes classified
positions but this one has an
appropriation of 141 024 and 140 025.
any opposition to this
it raise your hand if you're in favor of
raise your hand if you're opposed
so there was an abstention there eight
zero one
retain
okay
okay so now we're on two three one
uh and this is this is a goofy thing it
just doesn't even feel to me like it
makes sense to have it but it doesn't
seem to do any harm either
it says you can't put we cannot admit
you want to go back to 230
yes
Nathan um do you know if all of those
positions are currently fulfilled
this is the attorneys underneath the
commissioner yeah so currently there are
there are six vacancies in that area
um this has been a key priority for
Melissa stains here she had spoken to to
the committee about this uh she's the
chief legal counsel and a number of
weeks ago
um and and it just the the part of the
reason behind this is that
the way that their work schedules
you know are need need to work out are
like they'll have workloads that
fluctuate one day or one week and then
they'll decrease so they're a little
less consistent um the workload in this
area generally has been very high and as
a result of those vacancies they have
been struggling with that and we we have
had increased comp time and overtime in
this area to meet those unmet needs okay
do you know I'm on page 79 whether those
are the staff attorney level or the
supervisory level or the supervising I'm
not sure the difference between the last
two this is a b and c on that section
the vacancies yes I don't know if top of
my head thank you
okay go ahead by making these
unclassified does that allow them to get
overtime and and that sort of thing
no precisely the opposite so
um by making them unclassified they
would not be eligible for over time they
would be subject to a standard 40 hour
break however if if the the business
needs require them to work 45 or 50
hours
um they would not receive overtime for
that work
you said they're not allowed to get
current well I thought I thought that's
what classified was classified was like
and what am I what am I thinking
unclassified
you can get overtime no no other way
around
that's right that that would be the
Commissioners and so on all right okay
thank you so we voted on this once so we
want to keep talking about it yeah just
one another quick question do we have
any idea how much the overtime was for
that
is there any way to figure that out
uh yes I I could figure that I would
just take take a little while just have
to run a couple reports that's fine no
problem thank you okay because I'm going
to start getting just a little
Persnickety if it doesn't affect your
vote uh let's let's try to move on
uh 231
I would remove it just because I think
it's dumb but hey we agree yeah
um but it doesn't do any harm other than
it's dumb
and there's uh I'm going to ask you to
raise your hand
if you want to
I'm going to ask you to raise your hand
if you want to remove 231.
okay
delete
allows
well this confirms the department of
statutory ability to carry forward funds
from three accounts the developmental
disabilities account acquired brain
disorder services and children's In-Home
Support Services I don't have any
amendments to this section but I don't
know
representative Earth did you want to
address
so if I'm not mistaken this is one of
the three accounts that for which
funds are continually appropriated yes
that's correct these three yeah so it's
these three that we should whole I think
I think CFI is another one coming up at
234.
and then the big one is it is the DD
account I believe which is further on
and and I would suggest we hold those in
terms of our discussion related to
Medicaid rates
okay
but that's just my suggestion I can go
into details as to why if the group
disagrees or wants to hear I I don't
mind holding do you want to hold him
okay
um so you got track on which three we're
holding
well I think this section alone you're
holding for now because this pertains to
three accounts developmental Services
acquired brain disorder and In-Home
Support funds
right but don't does also impact some
other
sections of the that we're going to come
I don't think so okay all right okay
fine you you want to do County cap
well sure but it kind of
the dog tells us with what I thought was
you part of this so should we hold this
as well so it's all one comprehensive
discussion that's fine with me I can
give an overview just real quickly of so
so you did that when I wasn't here the
county cap but we've talked offline I'm
okay with you doing what you're doing
okay is there is there anyone else in
the room that would like to hear a
synopsis or a summary of what
representative burf is proposing for the
county cap we'll have to wait for the
details in a detailed discussion until
Monday but actually do you have the
amendment just so people could could
have it for the weekend and read it
that'd be good
so we don't need to go through it today
did you have a question represent no
and if you'd like I can hand out the
house bill one side of this as well yeah
I do both that'd be a good idea and then
so he's simply handing that out there's
not discussion now so I'm going to go
ahead and start
Okay so
uh we're on 234 choices for Independence
program
that appropriates General funds in the
amount of 4.75 million and 24 and 10.35
and 25 to ensure adequate funds uh so I
I like choices for Independence for
about three or four really big reasons
the only the only issue I have that
causes me to stumble a little bit to say
yeah let's go ahead with this is we've
got the Medicaid rate increase
discussion going on in parallel and so
so I I just don't want to get myself
confused about if we say yes to this 15
million how that affects that
spreadsheet we looked at earlier and and
the totals that we're we're wanting to
spend so so because of that and because
I know we're going to talk about
Medicaid rates in more detail and we got
something on hold I would propose that
we hold this unless somebody wants to
I I'm I'm predisposed in favor but it's
just I just want to make sure that the
I agree with the hold I'm actually
predisposed to delete it just because
this Opera replacement funds and I think
we should use them the way you just
described what we decide to use them
with the whole rate process but anyway
so agree to hold so if we were to hold
it what it sounds to me you just said is
at the end of our discussion we're
likely to want to come back and just
delete this because we'll have taken
care of it elsewhere
and use the money elsewhere yes it's
still weight setting but not not
necessarily dedicated to this all right
so preview of coming attractions
uh
uh so just briefly so people understand
what they just got from Mr Ripple
so the intent here is to there's a
reason there's two pieces to it the hb2
piece which is the the vertical sheet
essentially not essentially this is what
it does it freezes the county cap at the
current this FY 23 level very
straightforward for the next two years
only does it make any changes to law
other than that the hb-1 amendment
reflects what's going on in HP one so
the governor um or the governor's budget
I should say
it incorrectly calculated the values
that are required by current law so if
you look beside description there in the
middle of the page number one it says
there's a 10 million dollars needed to
correct that mistake basically a little
bit in in uh 24 and a little bit in 25
and then the effect of the freeze the
part that I actually want to implement
is the 7.9 million across those two
years and then down below is are the
details which I won't go through them
right now but this shows you how it's
basically being accounted for so we're
talking about basically 17 18 million
dollars that that's going to suck up
from uh somewhere
so so that kind of goes into that whole
bucket of how where are we going to find
so we did this for the first time last
term where we reduced the the county cap
and in Rockingham County
uh they they loved it because what the
CFO told me was by us doing the uh
additional contribution that meant that
they could reduce seven percentage
points off of their total property tax
levy
so when we do this we're actually
directly directly helping the counties
reduce their property tax levies
the devil's in the detail but that big
picture view I I found important because
of the desires to cut property taxes in
so many corners
does anyone want to talk about this
further before we just hold it till
Monday
you look you look like you might have
okay oh yay let's talk about 235 the
mmis
was there an amendment on this what are
we doing on this
you do have an amendment did you decide
to skip
or maybe this is the one of the ones
that representative erf wanted to hold
on Section 234 funding for CFI
I'm looking at 235 we did hold CFI right
that's we are holding CFI to talk we
loaded that while you were walking okay
so we're on the mmis thing the um the
maintenance component
yes and I do have an amendment for that
and again it has both the house bill 2
and a house bill one component
um and so this is what the division I'll
hand it out just in a moment this is
what the division talked about the other
day allowing the department to carry
forward 20.5 million dollars and treat
it in the operating budget as restricted
revenue for the purpose of funding mmis
so if I can find those I'll hand them
out right now so so I think we were
trying to accomplish two things I think
from a principal's perspective
we were trying to
keep hb1 reflecting actual operating
expenses and so we wanted to get it out
of hb2 so that there would be continuity
and transparency on what we're spending
from an operations and maintenance
perspective in HP one into the future
but on the other hand this had
FY 23 carryover money associated with it
in hb2 and we didn't want to lose
that funding source from hb23 carryover
so so in trying to split those two
principles
Mr Ripple has has come up with an
while he's Distributing is it were you
listening to what I said is that
accurate with from your perspective what
yes I I I for just from a general
accounting perspective I think it makes
the most sense to be to include this in
in the budget
um within the within the operating
budget in HP one get it out of hp2
while simultaneously
from a revenue perspective not losing
the carryover from the current budget
yeah
okay this is carried over because they
never did the program right no no no
this is the ongoing maintenance contract
this is not the uh upgrade funding I
think it was in the capital budget so
one of the one of the pieces of
testimony you may not have been here for
representative Weiler was uh that it it
dawned on me if not anyone else how
wrong I was about how much it costs just
to do the operations and maintenance of
this system when I saw a 20 million
dollar bill last time I could have sworn
that had to be like a capital
Improvement
but it's not this is just a god-awful
expensive system to maintain and and I
it makes me very uncomfortable they're
taking it back out to reacquisition
they're doing a redesign to make a
modular so that they could plug and play
maybe less expensive components over in
the future but right now this just feels
to me like we've painted ourselves into
a very expensive Corner that we can't
get out because this system is essential
to us being able to document compliance
with the federal program
I remember several fiscal meetings where
we said it's
m-i-m-m-i-s up yet
and it was it was years delayed
okay so is there any discussion on this
let me go back to you Mr herbal since
you've been handing this out could you
just summarize for us what you think
we're doing now with 235 based on these
amendments sure if you adopted both of
these you would still be using fiscal 23
let me think about that for a second
yeah you would allow the department to
carry forward for use in 24 25 and so it
would show up in the operating budget
here as 24.25 and so on the line that
reads agency income that 9.7 million
that's being added in 24 and the 10.8
million that's being added in 25 that's
the amount that's carried forward and
the department would get Federal
matching funds on the next line so those
all right so we we have talked about
this before but it's a it's it's kind of
it can be a lot is there any discussion
can we can we can we give Mr Ripple
guidance on this now or do or is there a
desire to think and soak on this over
the weekend go ahead I just want to
clarify if I'm understanding this
correctly so I understand that we're
moving
um the appropriation to hb1 and I see it
over the two years it's 2023 money that
we are allowing them to do that
the amendment to hb2
does this simply say that we are
authorizing the department to spread
that 2023 money out through the end of
okay I just I think I just worked it out
in my head the the house bill 2
amendment is needed to allow the
department to carry those funds forward
from 23 rather than letting them lapse
okay and then the HP one Amendment
actually outlines how that is going to
be done yes okay I understand thank you
all right so
let's let's do a straw vote on this with
with the another reminder that we can
come back Monday and change our minds
based on what we know and what we think
right now are we comfortable accepting
the HP one and two Amendment as drafted
by Mr Ripple you have a
okay so so so what we're straw voting on
is are we going to accept the work
product that Mr Ripple just handed to us
and then if you oppose I think that was
unanimous
okay 237
so these are the funds basically for
unwinding
the Medicaid
permanent Medicaid so to speak that we
talked about earlier okay I I believe
that I was given this I should have said
Mr Ripple do you do you want to talk to
237 that's just what Mr representative
erf just said right I have nothing to
add
takes a chair go ahead I have a naive
question so I can currently hear that
we're unraveling the expanded Medicaid
and or unwinding I guess is the term and
then we're continuing the program
separately in the budget I don't know
how
to mesh those two ideas
well the unwinding period is phased in
over six to nine months I for I forget
the numbers we've we've had them brief
to us before but
um so the unwinding period takes a
period of time and while they're they're
doing that trying to get the people who
were only eligible because the federal
health emergency
offer the rolls they're checking before
they remove them from the insurance
rolls
as to whether or not they may qualify
for something else
so so the statistics on who might end up
on what is ambiguous because we just
know there's at least six to nine months
of work with each individual involved
and family individual and family go
ahead represent Stringham Mr White if
you could just comment what it says here
in the sheet we got is These funds will
be used to cover increased costs
resulting from the regular and Chip
increase in enrollees as the department
unwinds the program and disenrolls
individuals so to me that says that
there's maybe going to be a permanent
bump up in the number of people in the
chips program and that's part of what
these funds would be used for
um is that accurate or what would be a
better description so so the I apologize
if the description wasn't clear so the
primary purpose of this is to date for
standard Medicaid we've been receiving
6.2 percent as as a condition of the
continuous enrollment
um that phases out on April 1 where we
start to receive five percent first
quarter of State fiscal year 24 we
receive a two and a half percent
enhanced staff map and one and a half
percent in the last quarter of calendar
year uh 23. and so we this is an
estimate based on our analysis at a at a
rate level at an individual level where
we still expect to
um not have a sufficient federal funds
to enhance federal funds to cover
um kind of that that phase down so that
over nine months we're going to be
taking people off off the rolls so so
this amount here is to cover those costs
that for the past two years have been
cover two and a half have been covered
uh
so
um will there be an increase in the
number of people in the chips program
and has that covered somewhere else in
the budget
so right now we have we have experienced
an increase in the in the chip program
and and those costs have been budgeted
any further conversation on this
um
okay so we're down a member
so a really really informal struggle uh
on for 237
I the first raise your hands if you're
in favor of keeping
this hp2 item as is with no changes
okay no so it's unanimous
um all right so 239
audit of the integrated eligibility
system
but the name New Heights isn't on here
it doesn't need to be if it's the
eligibility system I'm just trying to
Okay so
let's have a little discussion of this
like we did mmis thinking that all of
the concepts are understood
is this a good candidate for what we
just did with mmis where we want to go
ahead and keep the s or the 23 funds but
this 838 really is operations and
maintenance
it's a one-time cost every two years
that's funny
okay
so
um that I don't know that feels like
operations are maintenance to me if it's
if it's got such a rhythm so so would
would we should we do what Mr Ripple did
with an hb2 and one Amendment to
operationalize the 832 what do you think
that that that's one option
what what do you think Mr Ripple since
you would do the work I think that's
fine if that's what the division wants
to do all right so that's that's what
I'd prefer to do because we then we can
be consistent we're trying to
operationalize costs and we're we're but
we want to take advantage of the 23
excess so is there anyone who's opposed
to
putting the operations money into hb1
instead of leaving an hb2 a
representative or if I'm curious what
you're thinking is well you keep
reminding us how how busy Miss Ripple is
and I know he's busy it just seems you
know for such a small sum of money
doesn't seem worth making the effort
I'll let him speak but because he's done
this with mmis this is probably not as
much time
didn't take too long I would suggest
that since the number is so small
compared to the 20.5 million for Mis
that you could just fund it out of 24.25
you wouldn't need to use this so we
don't need to worry about the 23 money I
don't think so just put it in an hb1 I
think so
so we might be able to apply that 23
money to something else
um what do you think about that that
sounds good
Okay so we've just changed we're not
going to fund this 830 million or a
thousand out of
uh 23 money we're gonna use current ex
money and then this 23 money we're going
to keep track of because it could be
applied elsewhere
yes okay all in favor of it does
everyone understand what we're talking
about because we that was a conversation
not a question so if you if you are okay
with that conversation raise your hand
opposed no one okay good thank you
so now we're on
um
audit oh wait that sounds we just did
that no wonder let's look familiar
241.
this section appropriates 533 000
General funds from 23 for the purpose of
moving one district office okay so this
is an even smaller amount of money so
why are we wanting to use 23 money for
this this is truly one time because this
is meant to be one time
foreign
all right so
just leave it as is is the thing to do
right okay uh raise your hand if you
think we should leave 241 as is
two four three
appropriates 200 000 of General funds
from the past into the future to replace
two vehicles which will not pass
inspection and outdated clinical
equipment
it just always bugged me that I never
saw the description of the vehicles or
the equipment and the 200 000 feels like
a lot of money but that's okay that's
not a yes or no vote issue but um I
don't think uh is there any opposition
representative hole
what's your opposition other than we
is that all
right representative Earth do you have
anything to add to that
I'm totally supportive
of it as written as written with big
caddies
it probably is well I when I first read
this I circled the vehicles and I was
thinking that's a whole lot of money for
vehicles but my mind flipped right over
the part that says clinical equipment so
that actually makes me feel better yeah
so I'm good with it yeah but we're still
just as ignorant as we were because we
don't know what they are we just feel
it would be better if it was so much for
vehicles and so much for equipment for
clarity okay but the issue is we're not
going to change this hb2 item if if you
have time it would be nice to know what
we're doing with the money though
thank you
uh do do do do do do we have do we need
to vote on that that seemed pretty
obvious all right raise your hand if
you're in favor of leaving it alone
Department
okay we'll have about well I think we've
they are fire trucks unbelievable you
can't touch a fire truck for two hundred
thousand so so uh we're on two four five
so we're taking old money
to support it systems design
that that can be one-time money
um it's something you should always have
a capacity to do but you can do one-time
projects on that well you may recall
that this is a new model for them these
that's both these 245 and 247 together
yeah and if it's successful which I'm
sure it will be then as they'll continue
using if they continue using this model
they said they would be separating the
budget okay so that sounds to me like
you're in favor of leaving the language
as is
I am totally in favor of that for both
of these is there any opposition to
not seeing any let's raise your hand if
you are in favor of 245 247 as is that
that's unanimous okay
so now we are on two four nine and and
Mr Ripple if you wouldn't mind thinking
about when we hit the bottom of this
list we we have what two or three brand
new things that aren't on this list
and
there will be a few new items I'm not
sure I have them all
but I might have a few new items to to
add to this when you get to the end yeah
okay so for those getting excited that
we're really close to the end that we're
not so
um
so two four nine
appropriates 125 000 General funds from
the past to replace aging Legacy
database used for pulling quality
samples for food stamp okay I I don't
know I just leave it as is
yeah all right
um I I'm not going to take a straw vote
that we've kind of done that one so
we're going to keep 249 as is unless
somebody tells me no
uh 251 appropriates 410 000 in general
funds from the past to replace aging
switches
okay so I'm I'm okay with that although
I consider switches routers and access
points more to be Expendable not durable
but um but I'm fine with it does anyone
want to change that hb2 item
okay so we'll accept the that we'll have
new switches and routers
um I have this is a TANF note and I S it
my note says we just agreed in principle
to move from hb2 to hb1 or at least I
thought we had do you want to talk about
this
253 yes we also had an email
conversation about this so I prepared an
amendment in your name this amendment
would actually keep it in-house Bill too
but I can hand this around for
discussion purposes if you'd like let's
this is this is all in an effort to show
our our minimum
investment right or whatever the term is
okay so I'm looking at this amendment
I'm remembering pieces of the
conversation
we are obligated to meet a maintenance
of effort in order to get the federal
funds and there are sort of penalties in
the future if we haven't done that and
so our maintenance of effort to me is
something that ought to be in hb1
because that's essentially our annual
buy-in to to be a full member of the
TANF Society so
um
what the hb2 item 253 did is it made
sure that we had the maintenance effort
money
but it really just ought to be an hb1 so
that we can see
annually or every two years that this is
an issue that we have to fund that's
what why I think we're doing this
amendment what what did what what else
would you say well this also this
reduces the appropriation from 3 million
per year to five hundred thousand
dollars per year oh so there's a five
million dollar savings over the two
years yes so I had sent out
a spreadsheet Nathan gave me of all the
TANF funds in the budget and technically
based on the budgeted figures the 32
million dollar maintenance of effort
requirement is met now as as Nathan can
point out to you the maintenance of
effort is based on expenditures not
budgeted figures
so this would provide a smaller cushion
to five hundred thousand dollars rather
than the three million that's currently
in the trailer bill
so in other words just because we
budgeted we we're not really done we
still have to spend the money in order
to qualify for the maintenance of effort
and by having additional funds budgeted
we're more likely to actually hit the
expenditures that we need in order to
meet the maintenance level the
yes I think so this just budgets
less extra than the yeah than the
governor's bucket so so we're we're
pairing it back a little bit so we're
accepting a little bit of risk with this
Mr White what's your perception of the
risk that we're increasing because the
it's not a budget risk and I and I
actually don't see that it could
increase the risk of under expending
because that's going to happen whether
it's 3 million or half a million if
you're if you're not going to spend it
you're not going to spend it so I think
what's really important to point out is
that in the document that I had sent you
there's 2.8 million dollars of assumed
Revenue
um collected from non-custodial parents
um if we don't receive that then I don't
have the general funds budgeted to hit
the maintenance of effort
um the other the other side of this is
the way that we've budgeted that that
also assumes that all of those positions
will be filled so that we would hit that
we know that life happens and we'll
probably lose people we'll probably hire
people during that time frame the reason
just from a uh just so everybody
understands why this came in through a
prioritized needs request is because in
order to hit the three percent
um as required by the governor for the
efficiency expenditure requests under
rsa94 we we were not able to get all of
our TANF funds budgeted that came
through during the governor's phase of
the budget
um we we weren't able to get there and
that's why it ended up as an hp2
provision to provide us the cushion that
that we need and I don't know if cushion
is really an appropriate word here
because in that document that we have
sent there's assumed there's assumed
amounts the assumed amounts are never
the actual experience so I would be
pretty concerned that we may not hit
maintenance of effort and we would be we
would have fewer funds fewer TANF funds
available in future years
not just fewer but we'd be penalized and
we'd have TANF additional Tana funds uh
prohibited to us
correct this isn't just a matching issue
this is also a potential penalty issue
correct
all right representative we'll only have
comment on this what do you what do you
think well I don't feel comfortable with
the 500 000 I mean I I feel like
risky to uh not provide the three
million it is needed in this line
is is it is it the case that the 3
million is there because you looked at
the 2.8 that we're supposed to get from
Collections and you're assuming a risk
possibility of zero of the 2.8 so
therefore you went with three million
what how did I I'm just trying to
understand your confidence level on the
three million is it really 2 million is
it a million how did you get to 3
million sure so so there's there's the
revenue component which which is the 2.8
million that that we have assumed but
then there's the actual spend because
the budgeted amounts they matter but
from a maintenance of effort actual
spend perspective they don't matter so
what what we would likely you know if if
we were to receive that three million we
had vacancies in our positions or
whatever it might be or we had we didn't
collect all of those revenues that we
had anticipated we would likely have to
spend those dollars in cash assistance
and we wouldn't spend the federal funds
that we have in the cash assistance line
so if you're are you just to clarify are
are you are you looking for what is
what is a a slightly lower risk dollar
figure yeah I'm trying I'm trying to
make sure I understand all the mental
terms you know gymnastics you've had to
jump through that led you to 3 million
and I'm just basically challenge you to
go through your gymnastics and figure is
three million actually a little Rich
could you would two million really
compensate for what you think the real
risk is here you did you did the thought
so I'm just asking you what your gut
tells you is it a solid 3 million or
could you do with less and still feel
comfortable
I think what I would need to do to
really feel comfortable is to take a
closer look this weekend at the
Historical spend and talk it over with
the team
um
to be because again I I don't you know
from a state perspective I don't want to
put our TANF funds our our federal TANF
funds at risk
um so let let me take that back and take
a closer look at it to understand
um where where we could get to that
would still you know satisfy that need I
also recognize the challenge that this
committee has and the full Finance has
with with balancing the budget and I'll
I'll take that back and take a closer
look at that to make sure we can get
somewhere we can all agree to that would
be great I I can wait till Monday to
have the rest of that conversation is
there any other discussion or questions
that you'd like to ask here anyone all
right
um so I guess we got this on hold
and then we're on 254 probation a
million and the biennium for family you
know I know I don't maybe I got sent I
didn't I don't recall ever seeing a
I think I sent it out
foreign
email from Mr White
Family Resource Centers are
community-based resource hubs for
families where they can receive formal
and informal support to promote family
strengthening and well-being
then there's a link to an RSA that gives
the wellness and primary prevention
counsel the responsibility to designate
Family Resource Centers as quality
Family Resource Centers
and then two links with more information
so do these Family Resource Centers
operate under contract from DHHS or do
they come they do they come through as
vendors to us
yeah we we would contract those those
funds out so so the original
appropriation that the department
received was through SB 44 444 from this
past legislative session and the reason
that the department submitted uh
prioritized needs requests in the amount
of 1 million General funds in state
fiscal year 24 and 1 million in state
fiscal year 25 was to continue the
appropriation levels that the
legislature had authorize this past
session you have to leave soon do you
have something
I'm just trying to help okay so this is
a particular pilot program that the
Senate set up
and
I would suggest we take it out
and let them put it back in
so we can deal with them well because we
have other uses it's basically funding
related to I mean it's not specifically
related to Medicaid but it is that kind
of thing it's basically a behavioral
health program for kids and not that
it's a bad thing but given all of our
demands here being I said we'd look at
all of them and I think in one big
bucket whenever we finally get to it and
this could be could be part of that
bucket or just put it on hold for the
moment but basically
um I like when the Senate has to work
when we give them a budget
because our job is Pretty Tough well
this one's easy for them too if they put
it in and we took it out they could find
more money and put it back in
Mr Ripple I think has a list no no don't
give to put back in because we took them
out right Mr Ripple works for the Senate
as well so it's it's he's got it
I think what you're proposing at least
you want to hold it or do you want to
propose removing it I I know I'd hold it
as part of the bigger discussion of what
we're going to do with Medicaid funding
I'm good withhold yeah I just want to
point out this has to do with preventing
child abuse and neglect so I would like
much more discussion on it before we do
anything that removes well this doesn't
kill the FRC program this just is this
one particular thing which by the way
there's some requirements for reporting
which I grant you they're not due until
later this year but you would have
thought by now they would have had some
reporting on this you know supposedly
hot program and just to be clear
from the Dark Side this isn't an intent
to not do the million it's the the dance
that's typical here is we have less
money to play with than the Senate
because their estimates come later when
there's more money since this is
something that they own they would
likely put this back but when we put
this budget together and go to the floor
looking for votes
our budget is a little bit smaller so if
it helps us get through that wicket
it still doesn't hurt the process I
understand the need to thread the needle
here I just before we jump to anything I
I guess I personally would like to read
more about it to make sure that I'm not
asked why I am going to cut a line item
for something that prevents neglect and
child abuse that's it we can discuss it
on Monday I'm pretty sure we're all
anti-child abuse yes okay
so
[Music]
um
okay so that gets us to the bottom of
all the uh
no no no tell me we're done
oh God I got excited
all right so we're on 255 Title 20
I have the notes that there's a match
and this was prioritized spending what
what else can you tell us Mr Ripple
if I remember correctly this just keeps
the flat funding of what we're paying
now no it does more than that it it this
when we went into the pandemic we had
extra Federal money that we knew was
going to go away and we told everyone
when we gave them extra Federal money
don't get used to this extra Federal
money well this is us with the extra
Federal money going away coming back and
replacing that with General funds
despite the warnings that the money
wasn't going to continue after the
federal funding was gone so so
um at least that's the way I remember
this is this is it did I say anything
you you would say it different but the
I I would ask Nathan again to weigh in
sure so we did receive arpa funds they
were used to increase the mill rate from
6.65 cents to 8.11 cents this provision
would keep those at the current rate
um without without the additional funds
we'd either reduce the rate or reduce
services
so we're not we're not really replacing
the ARP of money wait a second yeah
we're still replacing our we're
replacing funds yeah yes okay go ahead
representative
foreign
I remember hearing something about a ten
dollar rate was that an additional
request or was that buried in this one
as well ten dollars per meal
I can talk to that the ten dollars came
out of the uh prioritized list or
whatever we want to call it that came
from outside okay so that was moving the
Nathan when did they when did they
actually get the arpa funds
do you know I I wasn't in my role so I
don't I didn't experience it so I don't
know the exact date but at some point
during this current biennium I believe
in the first year in the first year
so they've had them
all the way through this this biennium
yes
so thank you Mr chair so Mr White you're
saying that the meals would continue to
be eight dollars and eleven cents in
this particular section is that what you
just said if this provision is approved
that current rate would continue if this
provision is not approved that rate
would likely either decrease or we would
decrease the number of meals provided
thank you but but we'll trade because I
heard you say an eight dollar rate and
then an 11 rate if we do this we go to
the eleven dollar rate if we don't do
this we'll probably fall back to the
Eight dollar rate I I I I don't know
where where the 10 or 11 dollar rate is
but but we had a 6.65 meal rate this
increased it to 8.11 okay I I think that
10 may be associated with an earlier
discussion a few weeks ago
um for the for for the homeless Services
where we were paying like a a per day
rate I think that's where the ten dollar
figure came from so so the obvious is
the food inflation rate means that we
probably need to go to the higher rate
right but so the only
policy thing for us to decide is do we
want to go ahead and step up after
saying don't get used to the arpa money
and replace the arpa money
if we look at those two numbers that's
closer to like a thirty percent increase
can you do that in your head real quick
and inflation doesn't seem like it's a
30 increase that's where I was going if
we're going to choose a different number
I would choose it more in line with
give them to me I'll do it on my
yeah so so that that's uh approximately
22 percent increase however
um if if you go to the supermarket you
know three years ago to what you're
paying today it's probably close to in
all right so I'm gonna I'm gonna hold
this so that people can contemplate over
the weekend what I think the real policy
implication here is it's not it's not
the it isn't just the money it's that we
said don't get used to the extra arpa
money because we're not going to
guarantee you that we're going to
replace it and here we are
first instance the arpa money's gone and
and somebody wants to give them the
general funds so go ahead represent
Waller I think
I think we are promoting to the
advantage of the state
so that we didn't use General funds
did providers needed that rate increase
in order to provide those meals they
were I mean food prices were going up
the state all of us were fortunate that
there was a pile of money that came in
and we were able to use that for
something that we knew we had to do we
knew we needed to increase that rate so
I don't think it's fair to say to the
provider of the meal
that you shouldn't get used to it
because that we should then we shouldn't
get used to the high prices in the
grocery store I mean I just I just think
it really was to the advantage of the
state
almost more than it was to the to the
provider the provider needed that rate
increase the state found another way of
funding it
and we were lucky yeah okay so the the
money came because uh the the pandemic
created an uh an artificial temporary
surge in the number of people that
needed servicing and so in theory the
money that we got from arpa was intended
to cover that surge
and so the expectation was that that
surge wouldn't continue post pandemic
and so therefore if the arpa money went
away there shouldn't be an expectation
that the general fund would step in
that's that's what I think we did
what we're finding out is that even
though the arpa money went away the
price increases in the grocery store
didn't go away
and then there are still people who need
a home delivered meal probably more now
actually because the prices are so high
in the grocery store representative
Waller do you have a comment
yeah I was on Meals on Wheels board for
a few years
the um
this money is just a small piece of what
they spent
they get even though the people they
deliver the meals to give them very
small contributions
they do most of their fundraising
themselves so this is just our share
because many of them think they couldn't
make it without our share even though
they're out there probably raising the
majority of the funds themselves this
little bit keeps them going and don't
forget there's I don't know if there's
as many as it does in different
organizations but there's at least one
for every County
so
this is multi-organizations
so I hear you're in favor of keeping hb2
as written I am
okay so
um
well we're still we can still wait till
Monday but that just gives us something
yeah I'm just ask a quick question about
that yeah unrelated to supporting or not
supporting it so I I have accounts 7872
and 9255
um fund um meals and wheels are there
other accounts that you don't have to
look this up right now but if there are
the cons could you just let us know
sure are those from the email that I'd
sent earlier in the week everything's
from the email you sent yep
so if representative hole this year
I we can take a straw vote on that I I
would be in favor of
maintaining 255 as written
is there any opposition to them
okay
so
um if you're in favor of re leaving 255
as wrote and raise your hand
as opposed no one so we'll move on
uh 256.
appropriates General funds and the
amount of 870 000 and then 957 thousand
to increase foster care rates to be
consistent with the cost of raising a
child
now
is this one of those line items Mr White
that that three percent
efficiency budget caused us to become a
priority need
or or why why is this an hb2 item and
just not a budget request I guess is the
other way to say that this was a new
um
we we really need to do what we can to
have a strong foster care program and
I'm in favor of these rates I I'm I'm
okay with HP too uh item 256. is there
any opposition well this is a relatively
small amount of money I think if I read
read our uh
our briefing books correctly it's only
it's another two percent on top of that
um do you know if there was already some
increases built into the original budget
and this is on top of that
no so so the this this request is made
so so back in roughly 2019 the count of
Youth in placement was
about 1200 at a high and it sends one to
about 975 but it's creeped up back above
a thousand in in recent times but what
this would provide us this would provide
us with
this would increase the rates uh
generally by about 10 percent in the
first year and 25 percent by the second
year to move to move the amounts from
the low median income to the to the
middle income to try to better align the
rates with the families that that are
providing services
any other comments representative Holt
thank you so roughly a thousand children
that we're talking about in the foster
care system and this is above and beyond
some other appropriation HP one
or is this the total appropriation I'm
not this is in addition to it these
additional dollars would give us the
ability to to increase those rates to
try to encourage additional
participation do you know what the other
amounts are or is that easy is that easy
to find or point me to a line item in
hb1
um I I can certainly I I can dig that up
okay
so do you need that information before
feeling comfortable voting on this all
right so I would like to do a straw vote
on 256 on maintaining this foster care
item as is raise your hand if you're in
favor
uh it's all right uh who anyone opposed
I don't think you raised your hand what
you're going to wait okay so that's like
seven to uh zero with two abstentions
um all right
this is the 17 million dollars for the
3.1 percent
I
okay so so
you tell me how we should do this if we
actually end up targeting rates should
we take our efforts to Target it and
amend
it em 257 so that there's just one
comprehensive item or should we do the
supplemental separate I think if you
want to keep the 17 million per year
that's in there for 3.1 percent across
the board you could leave that alone and
then add a new section appropriating
funds for targeted rates and then
identify the provider types to which you
wanted to Target them but because the
hospital Association says they don't
need to participate in the 3.1 percent
it may be better just to amend this to
say more precisely what we intend to do
with the larger number
and you if the intent is to not provide
rate increases to hospitals I think you
need to amend this section anyway to
specify that and also to reduce the 17
million dollar figure yeah so so
Mr Anan since you're here
what we have assumed looking at all the
material and hearing you listening to
you is that even though we're putting
3.1 percent across the board you're
saying the hospital Association would
rather have your share of that 3.1
percent allocated to other care
providers rather than coming to the
hospitals is that is that a fair
unbelievable
all right you're the first one I've ever
met
so good it's a pleasure and an honor
um
so so I think we have to amend 257 right
to
wait I have 276 here on the list I have
282. what did did we get rid of 276 on
another effort
just let me see transfers federally
funded positions from the office of
chief medical examiner to the division
of public we got rid of that oh
yes that's the department of justice
issue in division one already addressed
that all right so now we're on two eight
two
statutory requirements for hospitals
applying for designation as receiving
facilities
um
and then 283 is similar it's a directing
I I'm I'm predisposed to wanting to
remove 282 and 283 because I think it's
an inappropriate uh unplanned
intervention of the government and to
the Health Care delivery system at a
detail level in which we have no
business interacting
so I would not do these two things are
some of our hospitals have all those
programs that they can
rely on in the first place so it would
are there other comments representative
Weiler
that we'd be this is important to the
governor I'm just wondering what do you
think about are removing these two items
well it's it's part of trying to get
them out of the emergency rooms I think
that's that's the that's the stated
intent and as we know oftentimes the
actual effect of something isn't what is
intended
if if we don't pass it does it make it
harder for them to get it out of the
emergency rooms or it they have to be a
designated receiving facility while
while you were out what one of the
conversations we had was what we wanted
to do with the additional money that we
thought we would allocate to above the
3.1 percent Medicaid rate on a targeted
basis
and I I talked through our first
priority and no one just told me I was
wrong but I talked through as a priority
to give the hospitals capacity uh in the
community to discharge patients into to
Target Medicaid to help create capacity
outside the hospital so they can be
discharged and to and then we would also
talk about
prioritizing community-based solutions
to intervene in that patient's care
before they end up in the ER so if we
can reduce the input of patients and we
can improve the output of patients we
should be directly addressing the
emergency room boarding problem that
that would be a major priority so so
it's that's a long answer to your
question that we would attempt to
achieve this intent but in a more I
guess market-based approach than a
command economy-directed way
I guess the problems we ran into in the
past with designated receiving
facilities is they would keep those beds
empty but still expect us to pay for
them on a daily daily basis
so they would be available and they had
the staff and they had everything else
they said you need to pay for these
every day whether we use them or not
because we're keeping them empty except
for this special
things and and uh so I don't know if
that's still an effect or or this is
trying to make it easier to designate
receiving facilities
I don't know we could ask stating the
what the what the what it says go go
ahead I I I'm interrupting
representative nordgren who had her hand
up but if you're following up on on
representative Weiler go ahead no go
ahead go ahead
um I I guess I would just say for one
thing we would be micromanaging the
system I mean we've heard already
numerous days of the issues with nursing
home Staffing and whatever part of the
issue is they don't have places for them
to send these people that's not because
they want to keep them and fill up their
ER beds they just have
issues with discharge availability
okay that's not what the 282 says
what it says is any facility May apply
no designation shall occur without the
express written consent of the
administrator of the facility to be
designated so that's not forcing anybody
to do anything in 282.
now I haven't gotten to reading the
whole of 283 yet but you seem to be
misstating what the intent of at least
that one is
that's possible
um 283 requires it well let me read that
one Mr
are you open to
comment
would you would you maybe obviously have
to introduce yourself but would you
would you then start by telling us the
hospital association's interpretation of
I'm sorry Stephen and president of the
hospital Association it is our view that
282 and 283 would compel any hospital as
a condition of their license to have a
certain number of designated receiving
facility beds
so let's just stay on 282. yeah can you
tell me where the words are that that
say it makes a condition of your life
politely said again it requires them to
have a certain number of designated
receiving facility beds as a condition
of their license so if you're going to
have a license as a hospital you would
be required to have
um a number of drf beds if you have 25
beds or less you'd have two if you had
26 to 100 yeah you'd have four
um and so on and so forth um
282 basically takes the hospital out as
an option for the May and then 283
requires the hospitals that they show to
receive licensing if I believe it
correct
that's what it means
282 already exists and they're just
removing hospitals that's correct that's
correct that's correct from the May I'm
sorry so 282 simply says these entities
can apply
to have a designated receiving facility
bed and it takes the word Hospital out
of that so a hospital could not apply
and in 283 you would be required
thank you so
what I think I just heard you say is 282
is enabling legislation and it's closer
to what representative verf is saying
it's not a requirement 282 is not a
requirement it's just sort of opening
the door to applying to for a
designation
it it's 283 that's the offensive part
282 by itself
is is not it doesn't sound
I would say there are hospitals that
have established designated receiving
facility beds and they've chosen to do
that
um
this would remove that capacity for them
to do that
representative it sounds like you've
done some homework here well I I don't
know if I've done homework but I read
through it pretty clearly because I was
confused and
um
282 allows all of those
entities community mental health
programs Community residents nursing
homes and other treatment facilities
that they may apply to do that but
hospitals are removed from that so
they're no longer
given the choice to apply to be a
designated receiving facility and then
the new section 283
so 282 is existing and not new
283 is new and it says hospitals must
I'm gonna that's not actually in there
but hospitals to meet the licensing
requirements must have those beds
available so it's requiring that the
hospitals participate
okay that makes sense to me can you just
tell me I don't have RSA 30 135 in front
of me where was the word hospitals in
that pre in that RSA previously
in hb2 it's X Out section 282 line 12 of
page 89. so I just have a question for
the hospital man then yeah
let's say 283 wasn't there
how would that harm you
if 283 was not there yeah but 282 was it
would it would presumably remove the
ability of a hospital to open a
designated receiving facility if it if
it so chose oh okay you couldn't do it
okay so
fair enough so if we wanted to eliminate
if for some reason we wanted to
eliminate 283 and keep 282 282 would
still have to be amended to add
hospitals back in
but why would we do that if it's already
in the law so the better approach is
just to kill them both
if
if someone is in an emergency room
waiting for a hospital bed
and this says You must have designated
receiving beds
is that just mean you can take them out
of the emergency room and put them in a
designated receiving bed can you do that
now
we if if if there aren't enough today if
there aren't enough designated receiving
facility beds available that's either
New Hampshire hospital or any of the
other private hospitals that have those
if there isn't a bed available they're
unable to transfer them to them this
would compel them to have bids I think
the challenge as we've shared is how
would we staff all of those
decentralized um you know beds across
the state where where would we find the
health care Workforce to serve those
patients That's My worry is that some of
those people that would be doing that
would be coming from New Hampshire
hospital the Community Mental Health
Centers and others that would only
exacerbate the problem we have today so
if you already have people in the
emergency room perhaps at the same rate
as these things two beds in a hospital
with 25 beds or less maybe four in the
hospital with 100 beds already in
emergency rooms waiting for designated
facilities
and then you were able to designate
facilities within the hospital would
that enable you to get them out of the
emergency room to get to those
designated facilities and is there a
steady influx of people that are sitting
in the emergency rooms waiting the
answer to the last question is yes the
ability to move patients if there were
designated receiving facility beds
available would certainly benefit
patients waiting in emergency rooms the
problem is I don't believe the solution
is going to create the pathway that
would allow all of those hospitals to
serve those patients because I don't
know where those staff would come to
serve them
is there a need is a receiving facility
bed like a private room with more staff
available it requires specialized
Services specialized staff clinicians
facility
uh you know a specialized facility where
they can be treated safely and again
trying to trying to do that with a
Specialized Service with a very small
number of beds really isn't the way we
manage you know other specialized
Services we don't say every hospital
should be doing open heart surgery
because of volumes and service and
expertise we don't do that in those
services and it's my view that we
shouldn't be doing that here we have
facilities that can do this and we need
to focus our efforts to make sure that
they have the resources they need to be
able to provide those Services I was
thinking it would give you the
opportunity to get him out of the
emergency room without putting them in
an ambulance just put them in the
elevator up another floor or whatever
but
you know it would seem like it was a
logical way to help get them out of the
emergency room but then but if we don't
have the if we don't have the the
expertise and the Specialties to be
Specialists specialized providers to be
able to provide those Services I'm not
sure what we would be where we would we
would be taking then so I have
represented Stringham representative
nordgren unless you want to go first no
I just wanted to comment there's there
there's a huge number of issues involved
and one of the main issues is Workforce
um they
they as as many other organizations and
businesses people are retiring early
they have closed beds because they don't
have staff so to think that you can just
take them out of the ER and put them in
a bed it can't really happen all the
time
representative yeah that's a good point
just just uh you know my understanding
and probably why this is stuck so late
in the hb2 is this came out of of
um a stronger need because of an adverse
decision for the state in regard to
where uh people who are involuntarily
admitted or undergoing a mental health
crisis are being parked in emergency
room so it's not just a matter of the
hospital having a bed it has to have a
bed that takes care of and provides the
services needed for emergency
mental crisis admissions first of all is
that that correct so so you know the
state essentially is
you know facing uh potential potential
payments for hospitals who have been
without their permission basically asked
to take care of these patients in
inappropriate facilities and so this was
one way to try to open up more possible
facilities I think it was thrown in here
pretty pretty late in the game and and
um uh and so I'm just wondering if if
you've heard of anything to try to uh
solve that issue
um uh you know aside from forcing every
hospital in the state other than the
couple of excluded categories uh to uh
to open up open up beds depending on
their size is there a better solution or
anything underway right now where are we
on that there are
there are a number of solutions that are
necessary to solve the the Ed boarding
crisis and there are a number of efforts
that have been ongoing the 10-year
Mental Health Plan and others that are
you know building out uh communities
based system of supports from beginning
to end right it helped mental health is
a Continuum so we need to provide
services on an outpatient basis so we
can treat people before they become get
into a crisis when they get into crisis
we can step in with mobile crisis and
Crisis Intervention when they need
inpatient Services we have that and we
have Services Post Acute Care
um we need all of that and we needed it
yesterday but there's no solution that
doesn't require additional inpatient
capacity yes there has been ongoing
litigation there was a decision
um recently that
my senses probably spurred some of this
on but the reality is we've got to find
a way to do this and we understand that
we understand a bed doesn't get created
overnight and we've been more than
willing to sit down and find a way to
solve that problem and get to a point
where we can say
at some point in the future in the very
near future Edie boarding will not
happen and patients suffering an acute
psychiatric crisis are going to be able
to get the care they need because that's
what this is about you know that's what
this is about this is about patients and
families in crisis and we we absolutely
want to help get there and I think
there's a path to to do that and we need
to get there and we need to get there
soon
so I want to thank you for volunteering
your testimony it was you know nobody
anticipated you being here it was very
helpful uh I would like to have a straw
vote representative Weiler's not here I
don't I don't think he probably needs to
be for this but
um what I would like us to strive out is
the removal of items
282 and 283.
from hb2
if you are opposed to that you can speak
now if you're in favor will probably
take a vote in just a moment anyone
opposed
question I know I stepped out of the
room for a brief moment we haven't
touched on 284 yet right
okay thank you you can go ahead with
I I meant to say 282 and 284 that we
would just remove them wait wait wait
what am I doing
right you said 32 and 283 which is
correct I just wanted to make sure that
we didn't discuss 284 when I was out of
the room because that is somewhat
related so we can move ahead with just
two and three okay so that's right so if
you are in favor of removing 282 and 283
raise your hand
okay very good
um
statutory provision relative to
involuntary emergency admission to
receiving facilities
what do we what what are we doing with
this Mr Ripple what does I forget what
this does one word or do you want Mr
sure I I believe when this was put
forward that this is part this is
associated with the 282 and 283 sections
um this specifically strikes the
language
um
you you'll it strikes immediately so uh
when you when you take custody of the
person to be admitted and shall be
immediately delivered uh such a person
to a receiving facility
so so that's pretty simple it just
hinges on the issue of whether or not
requiring an immediate action in this
environment is actually something that
can be done
right I I mean I think the reason that
the word immediately is being proposed
for deletion is because we just don't
have the capacity now to be able to
move people immediately because there's
not somewhere to take them is that is
that the correct understanding of why
this proposal is coming forward
I think I would probably want the chief
legal counsel here to have a
conversation about this
okay does does anyone have any thoughts
and also are you in favor of leaving it
or killing it
um thank you again Steven and president
Hospital Association I absolutely
believe this provision should be removed
um you know when a patient is in crisis
they need care and the statute has been
very clear that we should be doing that
right away
um and you know for 10 years we've had a
wait list and we've told patients that
they needed to wait and I don't think we
should continue to tell people to wait
um just because we're having trouble now
we need to be able to get to a point
where we can transport people
um so that they can get the care that
they need and I I don't think this
provision should remain so you're
opposed okay so so now if you would just
take the intellectual exercise and flip
it around and make the argument of
whoever wanted to strike the word
immediately what do you think they were
trying to accomplish and we're trying to
avoid
um the obligation to provide that
service and transport uh immediately and
I think that's not the right approach I
I get that but stay in the other
person's frame of mind for a moment
why why would they not want to do it
immediately what is getting in their way
what what it would absolve them are they
legal requirement to do so and to do so
immediately
okay all right well uh thank you does
anyone have any I think I think we
probably need to wait on 284 uh you said
do we should get the chief legal counsel
to come could we get the chief legal
counsel to come Monday what time do we
start Mr Ripple on Monday
10 o'clock
10 o'clock okay well I I think we can
try to start go ahead what
okay
okay so if if the chief legal counsel
come is that uh sear cyr
Melissa sincere
okay so
um we'll try to have her in and out and
just talking about 284 and then we can
all right so what's the new new stuff
[Music]
well I only have a few
there are a few others that will be
so so I propose for the new new items
things that I don't think we've talked
about really and in the discussion until
we see paper just doesn't really count
anyways so I propose that we just do an
introduction familiarization of what
these are and what's the Thought is and
so actually there are two of yours that
I like to like to show you before
they're introduced publicly
oh did I screw up no I just want to make
sure that you want them to move it out
right now so I'll want one I'll meet you
and we're going to take a a three-minute
recess
foreign
okay
um that was more than a three-minute
recess but uh
but I I think everyone got quite a lot
actually done so where where are we
we're in the we are literally in the
final stretch if you didn't stretch you
should have but but
um what
I had considered doing
was
introducing two amendments that are are
sort of ready but
I don't think the timing's right so uh
and I understand there may be some some
other amendments that that we won't see
until Monday
which which the only issue with that is
I've been trying to give us the weekend
to think about things but that's okay
from your understanding of what you
might be bringing forward is it
something that we should I should just
anticipate we discuss on Monday and we
come back on Tuesday to vote or is it so
simple and so obvious that we're all
gonna
okay so I'll schedule Tuesday for those
laughs
yeah okay got it
um so so so then that's it I think we
did a a good job of getting all the way
through uh the open hb2 items
um so so thank you let's uh Mr Ripple
reminded me he gave me a flashback if
you'll remember that we had a pretty
good conversation going over this
document it's a long spreadsheet and
it's uh got two pages front and back
it's called Department of Health and
Human Services adjustment to Governor's
budget summary request by source of
funds if you find your copy it'll
probably have some notes on it because I
think we went all the way through the
yep and then we got onto the second page
where DHHS had some prioritized needs
and then there were other DHHS requests
and and frankly I'm oblivious where we
stopped off on the DHHS prioritized
needs well I remember these were pretty
pretty big numbers and that we hadn't
decided on any of them
so
I think that's right I think one thing
that you could consider doing is looking
at the other HHS requests a few of these
probably would be pretty pretty easy to
vote on this afternoon there will be
some that will have to remain on hold
but for example
uh item number 24 the change request for
food protection adds 17 400 in general
funds each year and if you look at the
description that's because class 18 was
inadvertently reduced during the
governor's phase and also if you recall
HHS came in and had a prioritize need
which I think was for overtime is that
correct yes yeah and we've sort of
approved that on the Fly Right
so this this might be an item that you
could take a look at and vote on now
okay what else
I think 25 Family Planning may have to
wait uh representative erf has an
amendment to that that I don't have
ready yet I think the prescription drug
affordability board and the sununu
center may happen so let's stop on
family planning for a second this is
also the one where I suggested raising
the amount from 50 000 to
a hundred thousand with twenty thousand
incentive for new vendors that's correct
do we have that being written anywhere
it's I don't have it available right now
and representative verf's amendment is
it completed is it out of OLS it is not
it'll be available both of those will be
ready on Monday
mine is very simple I can describe it as
I can think about it my question was are
you open so that we do one Amendment or
should we do two members mine amends
federal funds there's defense General
funds okay let's do two amendments I was
thinking if we could just merge the
Amendments it's just easier but it's not
necessary
and it may not help okay so then there's
the pdab and I think that one will have
to wait uh we're waiting on a house bill
2 amendment to that what are we okay so
there is a big Amendment on the pdab yes
okay Anna and allocation of General
funds in anticipation of the portion of
hb2 that changes their feast and fine
structure to General funds that's
correct okay
now when we bring that forward
do you happen to have the gel car
transcript that goes with it so that
folks realize that it was a bipartisan
agreement that the fees were
inappropriate and that the legislature
ought to relook them I I can print out
more copies I think I distributed that
during the original discussion but the
jail car transcript has been distributed
yes okay
I think this new new center will have to
wait that was already talked about today
yeah
uh line 28 New Hampshire hospital
facilities and patient support this was
a request a general fund request of 150
000 per year which is why I put it in
the other category uh it's for PPE and
clinical Supply related costs okay so we
had Federal money buying all the PPE but
before there was a pandemic there was a
need for PPE
so is this an issue of just our needing
to get our our PPE consumption straight
and budgeted or why why are we doing an
out of budget thing for PPE sure yeah
this the the this was identified late in
the game and I'll attribute this to my
inexperience
um so basically many of the requirements
around PPE have continued uh New
Hampshire hospital has had outbreaks uh
over the past year
um and and to date uh we've spent 182
000 on PPE annualized over the Year
we're projecting about 274 thousand
dollars in costs associated to that this
request is to help uh mitigate some of
those costs in the future will likely
transfer funds from wherever we can find
them to cover the other costs as we cut
we at this point in time we expect many
of those requirements to remain in place
okay so have any of your clinical people
let you know that they think that the
we're at a new normal at PPE consumption
to where it's going to for as far as the
eye can see be it a higher consumption
rate
um or will we be going back to normal
my understanding is that for the for the
at least for the foreseeable future
um this is the new normal
okay uh what's going on with 29 then or
do you have a question go ahead no I
just wanted to comment
Department of Hitchcock and they think
PPE and wearing
gloves and masks is gonna go on forever
so
I would be okay with that if they have
the signs to show it actually reduces
infectious disease spread but you know
if it's science
all right so what's 29 29 has no net
cost it's just a movement of funds from
class 59 to class 10 but related to that
it does it is a request to convert 21
full-time temporary positions to
full-time authorized and so for this
reason I separated it out from the
okay so far what I have in my notes is
we probably want to hold
the Family Planning I think we need to
hold this one for discussion
did did everything else seem to flow oh
we're holding the pdab
well I know but I I'm actually getting
ready to loop back and and vote on some
of them in just a moment I'm just I I'm
just thinking of the ones that I think
we definitely have to hold I think so
far you'd want to hold on 25 26 27.
and I'm I'm not sure about 29. oh well
29 we need to hold I think and then on
27 we decided to hold that oh yeah right
all right so then we're on 30.
and 30 is just an increase of 11 000 per
year for copier costs resulting from new
procurement again I only threw it on
here because however small it was a
general fund request
so so since it's so small and it's
something that should have been budgeted
why wouldn't we just have the department
this is a recent change so Das goes out
to re-procure Statewide contracts on a
regular basis one of the results of that
just recently
um so our agency budget was again
submitted in August this is something
that's been identified in the past month
um as a result of that we do anticipate
increased costs okay and then how about
the last one I can't read the number 31
30. 31 is 139 000 in general funds and
24 and 145 025 for three additional
facilities positions
okay so we'll talk about that so so
I
in these numbers I can't see 24 28 or
30.
I I don't see those as controversial
8 or 30.
because if there's no opposition I'd
like to just do a straw vote to accept
okay
so so we're really only voting on 24 and
30.
all right one at a time though so so
okay are we on 24 and 30 any opposition
if you're in favor of both of those
raise your hand
okay now uh let's go sequentially we've
got we're going to hold on Family
Planning
we're gonna hold on the pdab
we're going to
um on the dcyf Staffing we're going to
hold
on the
facilities patients support this is the
PPE we're there now so you have an issue
what what what what is your concern
so
the quote Nathan right this is the new
normal but I also understand that
there's some science behind it and
hospitals were using gloves a long time
ago and continue to use and at some
level masks have been used in certain
places consistently but now we're we're
we're changing what is typically
personal protective equipment and
spending money and I would
I would vote against that one
is there a condition under which you
would support it is there a question you
would ask is there anything you would
need to have you believe that this is a
good line the justification to change
how standard equipment viruses have been
around for a long time bacteria has been
around for a long time we've been
practicing standard PPE procedures for
for a very long time we're now at the
point where it's minor changes to like
incoming staff potentially in the
waiting room side of the things as
opposed to the direct care so I'm just
not convinced but if there's science
that supports it I would I would gladly
take a look at it I'm willing to vote no
and be in the minority all right all
right
you know because I'm not a virologist
and and training infectious disease I'm
going to trust the Health Care system to
figure out what how they should dress
when they're going into a contaminated
area my instinct says they're over
dressing but that's their decision so I
I am I am okay with this line item is
there any opposition to this line item
other than representative hole
representative burf do you have a
question
or your post okay all right so raise
your hand do you have the co-head
representative point I mean I don't
understand whether this is just because
ppe's gotten more expensive than than
they expected or whether they're using
it more often and um it does seem to be
a pretty common line item for for most
Hospital facilities so you you lean a
post until you get a little more I'll
support it they need I kind of lean a
pose too so what what ask ask Mr White a
um
uh so is there any uh information about
you know why why they're spending more
on PPE are they using it in more places
or just a matter of of of uh and you
know I see the see the item they've
gotten some support before but if you
compare it to four years ago uh is it a
dramatic difference in utilization or is
it just costlier now
um it's it's an increase in utilization
based based on Health Care standards
um four years ago you know if if there
was uh there wasn't a and and acute and
you know disease that that could shut
down a whole wing and that happens today
so if there's certain protocol that they
have to follow
um this helps prevent those kind of
outbreaks because if they have to close
down a section or a wing of the of the
hospital because 11 12 15 staff are out
that have all tested positive for covid
um then you know it's it's essentially
The New Normal and and right now
um we're projecting again about 287
million 287 thousand dollars in PPE
costs for this state fiscal year so this
this request isn't even sufficient to
cover that
um we're just requesting that a portion
of that
um anticipated cost in the future year
be covered
so what was your PPE budget four years
ago
it was not this I I can I can certainly
get that I think the amount of the
amount that they spent on PPE was
nowhere near what we spend on today
okay so so my observation is in fact
four years ago we did have viral
diseases and we did have Infectious
Disease Control and we had preventative
measures but that this pandemic has
caused us to escalate our posture and so
like I said I'm I'm in no position to
review what they've done to increase the
posture but it it would just be nice
given the revelations about the lack of
science around masks that somebody has
actually done
some science here and come to a good
conclusion for utilization I know that
when people walk into a hospital they're
handed a mask which is ridiculous
because we know that the Mask doesn't
actually do anything it's it it so
but I don't want to I'm not ready to
fight that fight this time around it's
just it's just stupid and it's something
that's happening and I I I'm I'm still
in favor of just voting for this do you
want to wait till Monday to to vote no
no I'm okay voting now
okay I
you'd like to vote okay if you're in
favor of this 150 000 line item raise
your hand
if you're opposed to representative hole
okay that's good this is what keeps us
this strength from the Pollard Bureau
um
so we're on
Hampstead Hospital operations I wanted
to defer this because I imagine
representative hole and others may have
a lot of questions about converting
temporary people to permanent
do do you want to articulate your own
question
I understand correctly from the
testimony earlier right this is we took
over the hospital these positions were
partially funded for a part of a year
and now we are making them full-time
employees if I
so the the process by which we typically
create full-time authorized positions
happens actually in February of 2022 we
submit those to the governor's office
those are input into the budget system
and then those would come through as the
full-time authorized positions because
we purchased the hospital outside of the
standard budget process we use dop
Personnel rules to establish these
full-time temporary positions uh just
because we were in the off season this
would convert them to reflect the fact
that they are now critical features of
Hampstead Hospital they they are their
full-time employees normally when we
have full-time temporary employees it's
because there's a five-year Grant or
some kind of temporary funding source
this is an instance where for all
intents and purposes we would expect
that these positions would be here 10
years from now
follow-up um as long as I'm assuming
this to be true the salaries are
consistent with what they're hired at in
terms of the conversion I don't have any
okay is there any uh opposition to this
line item
I'm not seeing any so raise your hand if
you're in favor of item what is that 29
yeah
representative norger and I assume
you're a yes
okay
all right I hate those assumptions
uh okay so that's okay uh 30
uh we did right
okay so then we're on 31.
this is this is another kind of
personnel related item do you want to
just tell us again what you've already
told us
sure so um when commissioner Weaver came
in to talk about facilities she talked a
little bit about how in the um in this
in the most recent uh hb1 chapter 91
laws of 2021 uh a section of RSA was
deleted that section of RSA required
that the Department of Health and Human
Services enter into an mou with the
Department of administrative services to
articulate what services would be
provided to the department for its
support of facilities
after that provision was struck we we
actually used to have about eight Das
Personnel embedded within the Brown
building within the main Department of
Health and Human Services building those
positions have since left some of them
have retired this request is to get
positions to kind of fill that Gap in
services so right now we don't even
necessarily have staff to do desk moves
something simple like that or set up a
cubicle
um you know that's right now our
director is actually having to go out of
her way to do that kind of work we also
lost our position
um a position that previously wrote and
managed all of our lease agreements for
the Department this request is is
seeking that administrator position
would would fill that responsibility
that was previously filled through that
mou with the Department of
is there anyone opposed to line 31
not seeing anyone let's do estravo if
you're in favor you'll raise your hand
all right it passes so I think we've
gone all the way through the sheet do
you have anything else for us I'm
wondering if the division is able to
vote on the other components of the
alcohol fund changes that I handed out
this morning
or
I'll it feel it felt to me
representative Waller that on the
Alcohol fund that you guys wanted to
absorb the changes and
discuss the changes and wait till Monday
or do you think you might be ready to
vote on
it is Friday night it's a good time to
we'll just leave it till Monday at this
you're winning
foreign
all right we're in adjournment uh
no so so let's just wait okay anything
else in that case I have nothing else so
on Monday I'll come back with a list of
everything you've done an updated list
of House Bill 2 and I think we'll also
go through
um either Monday morning or Monday
afternoon
after the full committee is done with
its exact session uh we can go through
all of the HHS divisions and make sure
there's nothing that people want to talk
about that's been left out okay so last
year or two years ago it seemed to me
like there were some major categories at
the hb1 level like Glen Cliff Veterans
Home New Hampshire hospital and we just
did like a blanket vote on those so
we'll we'll accept the governor's
proposal
two years ago but okay I I think that's
that's the only way I remember so this
you know since this is my only year they
Okay so
so I would like to
identify those major divisions where we
don't that we already just agree that we
don't need to get into the weed zone or
or do you think you're going to want to
go into hb1 and atoms and specifically
well I mean I think that
here we are we've got
what one and a half days left that we
can do it
I think we should have been doing that
exercise
for the last month
going through the divisions and looking
at the budgets and deciding if we
thought those I don't think there's time
to do what you've just uh going through
the budgets and trying to decide whether
they're appropriate or not appropriate
so here we are at the last minute
yeah I think the best we can do is just
vote vote for them up or down by
divisions or by
you know major organizational sir
representative Mooney would you
summarize for us all of the emails that
you've received after every one of these
briefing sessions where you've invited
people to provide feedback on particular
areas that we had heard that day
in terms of responses so just so the
audience knows I've sent out emails to
the division after each presentation
asking for any input or feedback for
house bill 2. and I have received some I
recall from representative hole
and representatives representative erf
to my knowledge now there have been
conversations related to the emails but
in terms of responses those two
come to mind as having responded you
just limited it to hp2 but after every
division people could have commented on
hp1 as well could they not
yes
okay so so given that we pay attention
to those emails
um like for example I need to ask you
still represent Waller are we are do you
still think we need represent or Mr
Monahan to come in on Monday to
specifically talk about his spreadsheet
well I think it would be would have been
helpful to have had
someone who could speak to that
spreadsheet I mean anyone looking at it
probably can think of a few questions
they might ask about it
um but like I said here we are at the
last minute so
um you know maybe maybe people want to
move on without without that
conversation uh I you know people wait
to the last minute to say what they
think then you can't do anything until
the last minute so ever I think every
response request I've gotten through
email to representative Mooney I've
factored into what we're doing so you
know if there's been a delay I think
it's been a shared responsibility on the
delay
so
um I I think Mr Monahan is in
Puerto Rico
right so he's not going to come up today
to talk to us so so if these is he going
okay so let's ask him to stand by to
come talk to us on Tuesday and we'll
find out on Monday if we still need him
uh is there anyone other than Mr Monahan
who could speak to that spreadsheet
let's let's see if we can get Alex to
come in on Monday and uh he can give it
okay are there any other requests on
what we should do on Monday well I I was
just going to say that um
um that
uh Mr Monahan was in in one way kind of
a scribe in putting the whole document
together so there were a team of
requests some some we heard some
comments on today from the New Hampshire
Hospital Association
but there was a large group of people
involved I think Tuesday I sent out a
series of questions
um back to try to get some clarification
on the rationale and some of those
things I've gotten some feedback which
anything I've talked about today was
based you know included that but I I'm
hoping to get more and I I even got
indications that I would get some more
feedback today so
um
uh
you know if we had three weeks then we'd
be that much better but I'm sure it
comes down to this kind of deadline
every time this isn't part of the normal
process and we'll do the best we can
with the information that we have and
the timetable
um you know that will follow under your
leadership
okay
um any parting comments representative
to make you aware that I have an
amendment for a very small amount that
we can I guess discuss on Monday is that
the Middle School thing
okay
all right and rep Mr Ripple is aware of
it Mr Ripple's already drafted okay very
good
anything else
okay
um I'll see everyone at 9 30 Monday have